Heute im Rasenfunk?
Der blickt auf andere Menschen.
Jetzt nicht umschalten, ihr seid genau richtig, bzw. warum sollte man bei einem Podcast umschalten? Das fängt ja schon mal ganz fantastisch an. Herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk zur Liga Tour. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und hallo liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer auf YouTube. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die Serie A, die Premier League und La Liga. Die Ligue 1 hat es leider nicht in die Liga Tour geschafft. Das hat aber rein terminliche Gründe, hat nichts mit der Liga zu tun. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ich hier begrüßen kann. Zum einen Christian Bernhardt. Hallo Christian. Außerdem Alex Treuker von unter anderem viva la liga.de. Hallo Alex. Und dann ist hier, wir haben ihn schon im September mal gehört, Hendrik Buchheister und wir können endlich sagen, nicht nur warum du deinem Namen alle Ehre gemacht hast, Hendrik, sondern auch warum du in der letzten Saison so selten in der Liga Tour warst. Hallo Hendrik. Ja, Herr Buchheister, warum waren Sie denn so selten da in der Liga Tour letzte Saison?
Ja, habe ich noch nie gehört, den Wort tatsächlich.
Ich habe einen Ruf zu verteidigen.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe ein Buch geschrieben, was auch gerade erschienen ist, heißt We Call It A Klassiker. Genau, vielen Dank für den Hinweis. Handelt von der Rivalität Deutschland-England, ist gerade erschienen, gibt es überall, wo es Bücher gibt, beim Pieper-Verlag, online, natürlich auch bei der lokalen Buchhandlung und macht sich sicher auch gut in der Weihnachtsbaum. Also ich kann verraten, für meine Familie wird es dieses Jahr an Weihnachten keine Überraschung geben.
Moment mal, die haben sich das nicht selber gekauft? Ja, sehr schön. Also We Call It A Klassiker, sehr empfehlenswert. Ich habe schon mal kurz reingeblättert, aber ganz gelesen, leider noch nicht, aber das werden wir ja vielleicht auch noch mal im Rasenfunk aufarbeiten können. Schön, dass du auf jeden Fall mit dabei bist, schön auch, dass ihr anderen da seid und schön, dass es dieses Format gibt. Warum gibt es dieses Format? Wegen Hörern und Hörern wie euch, wie dich da draußen. Diejenigen nämlich von euch, die uns unterstützen finanziell, die machen auch so ein Format hier möglich. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub, da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann und aus kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr neben das Buch von Hendrik dann noch andere Dinge legen. Vom Rasenfunk, zum Beispiel eine Rasenfunk-Tasse. Das wäre doch auch ein schönes Geschenk. kiosk.rasenfunk.de. Und ich werde natürlich das Buch auch verlinken, wobei ihr, glaube ich, schlau genug werdet, es auch selbst zu finden in den Buchhandlungen dieser Welt. Also danke für euren Support und wir wollen mal reinblicken auf die verschiedenen Ligen. Wie gesagt, heute sind es in Anführungszeichen nur drei. Und jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, wir beginnen vielleicht mal in Spanien, denn irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, dass das eins der Premier League Themen so ein bisschen ausufern könnte. Deswegen beginnen wir mal schnell und knackig mit einer Sinnkrise. Alex, wer oder was hat denn da eine Sinnkrise in La Liga?
Ja, ich habe es mal so betitelt, Sinnkrise. Der FC Barcelona krieselt ein bisschen. Das ist jetzt natürlich nicht bei denen so, dass sie jedes Spiel verlieren, aber sie gewinnen nicht genug Spiele und sie überzeugen bei ihren Siegen nicht. Die teilweise, ja, Arbeitssiege sind glückliche Siege. Und man hat sich natürlich mehr vorgestellt, nicht nur, weil man natürlich amtierender Meister ist in La Liga und da den Titel verteidigen möchte, sondern optimalerweise willst du ja eine Entwicklung sehen, den nächsten Schritt gehen. Aber es ist eher, hart gesagt, eine Entwicklung zurückzuerkennen. Am besten daran zu erkennen, an der Abwehr, die ja letztes Jahr ein absolutes Bollwerk war, weil auf Rekordkurs der Stegen ständig die Null gehalten hat, mit 9 zu Null Rekord eingestellt, aufgestellt. Ansonsten haben sie aber nicht so überzeugt spielerisch, viele 1 zu 0 Siege. Und mittlerweile, und deswegen Stichwort Zurückentwicklung, hält nicht mal mehr die Defensive und dann schießt die Offensive nicht genug Tore. Und dann gibt es statt 1 zu 0 Siegen oder 2 zu 1 Siegen oder 2 zu 0 Siegen eher mal hier und da ein Remis oder sogar Niederlagen. Und jetzt sind sie so, nur vierter in La Liga. Das ist nicht den Ansprüchen genügend. Viele Remis gegen kleinere Mannschaften, gegen Rio, Granada, Mallorca zum Beispiel geraten oft den Rückstand bei Schachtio Donetsk in der Champions League. Haben sie ja sogar verloren und deswegen ist man ja sehr, sehr unzufrieden beim FC Barcelona. Oder generell herrscht jetzt nicht so die Euphorie, die man ja eigentlich erwarten sollte in der Schafi-Ära als amtierender Meister den nächsten Schritt machen. Nee, es ist eher irgendwie eine Stagnation oder eine Regression sogar ein bisschen.
Jetzt ist es ja aber bei solchen Teams wie Barca auch so, dass eben schon ein knapper 1 zu 0 Sieg reicht, dass die Alarmglocken angehen und oi oi oi oi, wie schlimm ist es das hier? Also wie würdest du denn jetzt bewerten, wie viel ernsthafter Sinn steckt denn in dieser Krise?
Ja, du hast es schön angesprochen. Normalerweise reichen ja selbst unschöne 1 zu 0 Siege nur dann aus, wenn du dann wirklich reihenweise gewinnst, Titel gewinnst und dann der Zweck heiligt die Mittel. Das klappt ja bei Barca nicht so, das passt nicht so. Sondern man will ja wirklich auch immer dominanten, schönen Fußball sehen. Schönheit liegt natürlich im Auge des Betrachters, aber Schönheit für die Barca-Fans, für die Katalanen, ist halt nun mal viel Ballbesitz. Den Ball laufen lassen, dominant sein, viele Torchancen haben, den Gegner mit Ballbesitz ersticken. Und davon sieht man zum Beispiel auch sehr wenig. Also auch bei Spielen, die sie nicht gewinnen, wenn du wenigstens diese Stilmittel hättest, dann wäre man zwar unzufrieden, wenn man nicht gewinnt, aber man wäre zufrieden mit der Spielart und Weise. Und jetzt kommt halt eins zum anderen, dass sie nicht mehr so viel gewinnen wie letztes Jahr und der Fußball aber nicht besser geworden ist, sogar eher ein bisschen rückständiger, schlechterweise, nicht mal kleine Mannschaften dominieren können, nicht mal wirklich überlegen sind, sodass du sagst, das Unentschieden war unglücklich, du hattest 80 Prozent Ballbesitz, 25 Torschüsse und spielst halt eins zu eins passiert. Nee, auch das ist nicht der Fall. Sie sind wirklich teilweise gleichwertig und das ist sehr, sehr negativ, gegen Granada Radio Mallorca. Sie müssen mit Achunkrach irgendwie Remis erkämpfen, hinten raus, nach 0 zu 2 Rückständen und das Remis ist nicht unverdient, sondern leistungsgerecht und das ist dann schon natürlich nicht annähernd den Anspruch genügend und vor allem dadurch, dass sie die Entwicklung genommen haben letztes Jahr, weil sie ja so stark in der Defensive waren, unmeister wurden, hast du eher gedacht, okay, die Defensive passt, die nächste Entwicklung wäre jetzt noch schöneren Fußball zu spielen, aber nee, jetzt passen nicht mal die Ergebnisse teilweise und der Fußball ist auch nicht besser geworden, eher ein bisschen schlechter.
Okay, gleich müssen wir zu den Gründen kommen, aber ich will mal kurz die anderen beiden mit rein holen. Wie ist das denn zum Beispiel bei Manchester City? Ist es da auch so, dass quasi schon, wenn man nicht dominierend genug seine 1 zu 1 oder 1 zu 0 Siege holt, dass da schon die Kritik losgeht?
Ja, das liegt ja in der Natur der Sache so ein bisschen. Ich meine, bei Manchester City ist es halt so, das klappt mit den Ergebnissen halt noch einigermaßen. Sie sind nicht so dominant wie in den vergangenen Jahren, das stimmt schon, aber sie sind ja trotzdem noch ganz gut im Rennen und bei Manchester City weiß man halt auch, also das hat sich auch über die letzten Jahre so ein bisschen eingespielt. Die haben halt ihre Serien in der Regel immer nach Weihnachten. Also es kam auch in der Vergangenheit schon vor, dass sie, dass sie die erste Saisonhälfte so ein bisschen so lala anlief und dann aber nach Weihnachten gewinnen sie dann 20 Spiele in Folge. Und dann rokelt sich das alles zurecht. Und ich glaube, daran ist man in England mittlerweile gewöhnt und darauf setzt man auch an diesem Jahr.
Von daher ist da die Kritik, große Kritik gibt es da aber nicht.
Und ich glaube, sie spielen ja trotzdem dominanter.
Dieser dominante Fußball ist natürlich trotzdem da. Die Defensive ist nicht so sicher, wie vielleicht in der Vergangenheit. Das hat man jetzt auch gegen Leipzig wieder gesehen. Aber insgesamt, dieser dominante Fußball ist ja trotzdem da und sie können doch immer ein, zwei Gänge hochschalten.
Ja, und bei Italien weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht, welches Team das eigentlich ist.
Ich muss da grenzen, vor allem bei Alex, weil Massimiliano Allegri kann über Ästhetik-Diskussionen nur lachen. Also das Juwe-Motto lautet ja, gewinnen ist nicht wichtig, sondern das Einzige, was zählt. Und gerade Allegri begleitet ja seit Jahren so eine Ästhetik-Diskussion, dass sein Fußball nicht sehr anzählig ist und er argumentiert immer, am Ende zählen die Ergebnisse. Die haben die letzten zwei Jahre definitiv nicht für ihn gesprochen. Da sind ihm die Argumente ausgegangen. Das ist ja das, was Alex auch angedeutet hat. Wenn du so eine Spielweise hast, dann sollte es ja aber halt als großer Verein erfolgreich sein. Dann vielleicht nehmen die Fans auch manchmal ein bisschen Abstriche entgegen, wenn es dann vielleicht ästhetisch nicht so gut ist. Wenn du aber mit dieser Spielweise nicht erfolgreich bist und als großer Verein bedeutet, dass du halt ohne Titel da hockst, dann wird es schwierig. Bei Juve, da kommen wir später darauf zu sprechen, scheint es jetzt etwas in eine positivere Richtung zu gehen. Aber klar, die letzten zwei Jahre waren Beispiele dafür, dass wenn so ein Fußball nicht erfolgreich ist, dann wird es bei großen Vereinen in Unruhig. Ganz klar.
Gewinnen ist nicht wichtig, sondern das einzige, was zählt. Das ist ja fantastisch. Jetzt weiß ich endlich, unter welchem Motto meine Zwillinge immer, Mensch, ärgere dich nicht spielen.
Ja, das sieht man. Also da, wo beim FC Bayern Mia san Mia hinten am Trikot oben am Halsrand klebt, da klebt das bei Juve.
Steht einfach so rundrum. Genau. Okay, gut. Jetzt wissen wir, wie es in den anderen liegen ist. Aber Alex, jetzt musst du uns noch verraten, was sind denn die Gründe dafür? Muss Scharvi gehen?
Das waren jetzt zwei Fragen, ne? Also die Gründe sind vielfältig und so richtig ergründen kann man es ja selber nicht. Also Scharvi kann es ja selber nicht ergründen, sonst würde er es ja abstellen. Du hast ja keinen Knopf, aber sonst würde er ja Maßnahmen vornehmen, die es besser machen. Und das kriegt er ja aktuell auch nicht so richtig hin. So sind die Fragen sogar miteinander verbunden, weil man dann doch bei Scharvi ankommt. Gründe sind vielfältig und komplex. Sie hatten natürlich eine Verletztenmissere, das klingt immer nach Ausrede, aber Barca ist das wirklich ein Grund, wenn dir Petri drei Monate fehlt, das Herz der Mannschaft oder ein super wichtiger Kreativspieler, Frenkie de Jong fehlte, glaube ich, eineinhalb, zwei Monate. Der Motor im Mittelfeld, das sind ja auch zentrale Mittelfeldspieler, dann hast du natürlich in der Abwehr immer wieder umgestellt, umstellen müssen wegen kleineren Verletzungen. Das erklärt zum Beispiel, warum die Abwehr nicht ganz so solide ist wie letztes Jahr. Mal fehlt der Kunde, mal fehlt der Araujo. Natürlich musst du auch rotieren. Das ist also ein kleiner Grund, warum sie offenbar häufig recht häufig auch das 0 zu 1 kassieren, in Rückstand geraten, dass die Abwehr nicht solide ist. Ter Stegen ist auch nicht auf dem Superniveau des letzten Jahres, muss man auch ehrlich zugeben, sondern er ist auf durchschnittlichem Niveau. Letztes Jahr war er wirklich herausragend für mich, wahrscheinlich der beste Torhüter der Welt. Zumindest in Spanien war er mit Abstand der beste. Auch da gab es nicht mehr ganz diese Top-Niveau-Konstanz. Und vorne, Stichwort Regression, muss man über Robert Lewandowski einfach sprechen, dem man das Alter wirklich ansieht, der enorme Probleme hat im Spiel von Barca, der teilweise nicht stattfindet, der teilweise wirklich, das klingt blöd, aber Bälle stolpert nicht fest, verstolpert nicht fest machen kann, wenig Torchancen hat, wenig Anbindung hat und wirklich, wie ein mittlerweile, ich glaube, 35 ist er, das sieht man ihm auch irgendwie an. Also da ist man auch nicht ganz so happy. Ja, und so kommt halt eins zum anderen. Ein bisschen dem Belé-Abgang, zum Beispiel, muss man auch thematisieren. Er war ein Schlüsselspieler für Xavi durch seine Dribbelfähigkeit, durch seine Kreativität, Eins-gegen-eins-Fähigkeiten, die fehlen dem Verein da auch einfach auf der Seite. Und ja, so kommen quasi Puzzleteile zusammen, die dann dieses Bild ergeben und ja, wenn wir über einen Trainer sprechen, er findet offenbar auch nicht die Mittel, dass sich da was ändert. Also sie haben wirklich Woche zu Woche, vor allem in Auswärtsspielen oft Probleme, Teams zu knacken, Torchancen heraus zu spielen. So blöd das klingt, sie haben immer noch den höchsten XG, aber das ist nicht den Anspruch genügend. Wenn sich da Mallorca gut anstellt, dann merkst du, so richtig die Mittel haben sie nicht, um diese Mannschaft zu knacken. Und ja, oder das alles zusammengenommen ergibt dieses Bild, dass man sagt, ja man ist irgendwie so ein bisschen in der Krise, Sinnkrise, ist unzufrieden, sie gewinnen mal, aber es ist nicht ausreichend aktuell.
Aber Xavi ist jetzt nicht ernsthaft umstritten, oder?
Ich weiß, aber du weißt ja, wie es ist, wenn du viele Spiele nicht überzeugst, nicht gewinnst, wenn du den Klassiker verlierst, wenn du der Champions League bei Schachtier Donetsk bei allem Respekt verlierst nach unterdurchschnittlicher Leistung, schwacher Leistung.
Ich meine, da kann man schon mal verlieren.
Naja, die Ansprüche sind halt nun mal hoch und groß. Und wenn du diesen Ansprüchen nicht genügst, und wir reden über Monaten, also sie haben ja vor, im September und Oktober schon bei Mallorca und Granada schlechte Ergebnisse erzielt. Du hast natürlich einen gewissen Druck. Real Madrid gewinnt. Real Madrid hat dich im Klassiker geschlagen. Jetzt hast du übrigens Wochen der Wahrheit oder Spiele der Wahrheit mit Porto zuhause. Das haben sie jetzt gewonnen in der Champions League. Aber auch eher so war okay, war verdient, aber du hättest doch 2-2 spielen können. Also Porto hat hinten auch Chancen gehabt. Jetzt hast du Atletico am Wochenende, die vor dir sind in der Tabelle und die die beste Mannschaft in 2023 sind. Und du hast Girona nächste Woche, den Rai Flyern, dem Überraschungsteam La Liga, die eine grandiose Saison spielen. Und wenn du deren Fußball siehst, ist das genau der Fußball, der Barca enorme Probleme machen wird. Nämlich, die spielen mutig nach vorne, sie schalten stark um, sie sind gut im Gegenpressing, sind aufmüpfig, sie gehen drauf, also sie stressen Gegner, sie spielen mit unfassbar spazifisch, sie vertrauen selbst, das siehst du übrigens auch nicht an, dass sie das haben, oder du siehst an, dass sie das nicht haben. Also dann in Girona und Athletico kommen jetzt auch zwei Tests, die sehr, sehr schwer sind, die enorme Probleme Barca machen können. Und wenn dann die Ergebnisse nicht passen, vielleicht verlierst du ja sogar das eine oder andere, dann bist du irgendwann doch beim Trainer anbelangt, bei der Thematik.
Also dann gucken wir am 11. Dezember da nochmal drauf. Das ist der Tag nach dem Girona-Spiel. Vorher eben jetzt dann am 3. Atletico. Also 3. Dezember natürlich. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Ich dachte, ich mache einen Witz. Aber gut, Hauptsache ich war es nicht der, der die Diskussion losgetreten hat. Dann kann ich damit ein bisschen besser leben. Aber wenn wir bei Teams sind, die gewinnen, aber vielleicht nicht immer dabei überzeugen, dann können wir jetzt vielleicht auch Christian über ein Spiel sprechen, das du mitgebracht hast, nämlich das Derby de Italia. Und ich habe mir gedacht, wollen wir vielleicht alle Chancen der zweiten Hälfte nochmal durchgehen?
Die Zwei?
Das waren doch nur 1 zu 0 Torschüsse in der zweiten Hälfte. Ja, darauf kommen wir gleich. Da waren beide dann mit dem Unentschieden zufrieden. Ja, Juwe gegen Inter war am vergangenen Wochenende. Kurz zur Einordnung, Juwe gegen Inter ist immer mit das emotionalste Spiel in Italien. Deswegen heißt es ja derby de Italia, weil es über die Jahrzehnte einfach diese zwei riesen Vereine, weil die ganz oft ganz oben um die großen Titel gespielt haben. Dementsprechend ist jedes derby de Italia emotional, aber das Besondere an dem war jetzt, dass es halt zum ersten Mal seit einigen Jahren wieder um Platz 1 ging, was ja nichts mit Inter zu tun hat, weil Inter war in den letzten Jahren immer mit dabei, aber Juwe hat eben die letzten Jahre ausgelassen und jetzt war die Konstellation eben, dass Inter zwei Punkte vor Juwe in der Tabelle lag, 1 und 2, und dementsprechend war das Ganze halt nochmal angeheizter und bevor wir zur zweiten Hälfte kommen, also die erste Hälfte war gut, da war einiges los, da war hohe Intensität, zwei sehr, sehr schöne Sturmpaar-Duo-Toren, der nicht mal rausgespielt, also 1-0 wunderbar Wlauowitsch, Keza Wlauowitsch und 1-1 wunderbar Thuram Martinez im Zusammenspiel. Und das Besondere daran, deswegen hatte ich vorhin auch schon mal Juwe angerissen, die Frage war ja, Juwe kommt eben aus so einer Situation raus, die hatten in den sieben Spielen davor nur ein einziges Gegentor kassiert, also Allegri hat wieder komplett auf seinen Pragmatismus, pur Fußball umgestellt, so gut wie nichts zulassen, nichts kassieren und dann reicht halt auch eins oder manchmal zwei quasi, um die Dinger zu gewinnen und so ist es ihm gelungen, an Inter dran zu bleiben und dann war jetzt die große Frage, also spielen sie jetzt gegen Inter auch sehr ehrfürchtig, stellen sich hinten rein, schauen ob was geht oder probieren sie vielleicht auch selbst ein bisschen mutiger zu werden und ich muss sagen, die erste Hälfte hat mich positiv überrascht aus Juwe Sicht, denn da waren Ja, da waren solche Elemente dabei. Also du hattest das Gefühl, es ist ein Spiel auf Augenhöhe. Das Juve ist nicht sozusagen wie das Kaninchen vor der Schlange. Oh mein Gott, schauen wir, dass man da irgendwie rauskommt mit einem Unentschieden, nur vielleicht gelingt uns ja ein Konter. Sondern es war mehr Ballbesitz Inter, ja. Aber das hat Juve kontrolliert, sehr gut verteidigt. Also wenn Juve formiert, gestanden ist in seinem 3-5-2 oder 5-3-2-Tief, dann gab es eigentlich für Inter kaum Durchkommen, was schon eine Nachricht ist, weil Inter eben in dieser Zone einfach State of the Art in der Serie A ist. Also auch offensiv die torgefährlichste Mannschaft, die meisten Großchancen herausgespielt, die beste Chancenverwertung. Also Inter ist das Maß der Dinge. Und du hast gemerkt, dass selbst so eine Inter-Mannschaft, die echt einige offensive Varianten hat, dann an dem Juwe-Block auch sozusagen oft zerschellt ist und bezeichnet dafür auch das 1-1-Ausgleich-Feld, als Juwe aufgerückt ist. Also als Inter mal Platz hatte und dann ist Toram einfach im Moment, also wenn der Raum vor sich hat, dann ist das beeindruckend. Dann war es eben auch so ein Umschaltmoment, der das 1-1 für Inter dann relativ schnell nach dem 0-1 sozusagen gesorgt hat. Das habe ich als sehr positiv von Juwe wahrgenommen, dass sie eben mitspielen und wirklich du das Gefühl hast, okay, hier kann es in beide Richtungen gehen. Die zweite Hälfte war dann wirklich, da hat man wirklich relativ schnell gemerkt, die wollten kein zu großes Risiko gehen. Da darf man ja auch nicht die Tabelle aus dem Acht lassen. Im Prinzip war für beide der Punkt, okay, Juwe blieb dran, die zwei Punkte, und Inter blieb auf 1. Und dementsprechend hat weder ein Sage noch Allegri dem anderen den Gefallen getan, da vielleicht ein bisschen aufzutun oder ins Risiko zu gehen. Also ja, die zweite Hälfte war nicht mehr...
Ein Schuss.
Jaja, war nichts besonderes. Aber eben wie gesagt, also ich finde als Punkt-Sieger, auch wenn beide mit einem Punkt rausgehen, war es für mich Juwe, weil sie eben wie gesagt auf Augenhöhe dagegen gehalten haben, weil sie dran bleiben. Und jetzt der kurze Blick, deswegen habe ich sie auch genannt, welche Auswirkungen hat es aufs Meisterrennen. Wenn man sich die Konkurrenz anschaut, Milan und Napoli, A sind die schon ein paar Punkte zurück und B haben die beide so ein bisschen ihre Problemchen. Milan, also wirklich sehr enttäuschend jetzt die Heimniederlage gegen Dortmund in der Champions League, muss ich sagen, also die Art und Weise Riesenenttäuschung. Jetzt hat sich mit Malik Csau auch noch der vierte oder fünfte Innenverteidiger verletzt. Also bei denen ist es wirklich auch personell wahnsinnig eng. Napoli, glaube ich, fängt sich. Das mit Mazzari scheint zumindest die ersten zwei Spiele von der Leistung her gut zu sein, aber Napoli hat halt doch auch schon, jetzt schaue ich mal kurz, acht Punkte Rückstand. Also das ist schon ein gewisses Loch. Und Juve ist dran. Und das Besondere ist ja, Juve ist ja die einzige Mannschaft von diesen Top-Klubs, die nicht die Doppelbelastung hat. Und Inter bekommt jetzt eben, die haben jetzt noch das Endspiel und Platz eins in der Champions League gegen Real Sociedad. Da nahm sie im Januar auch die Super Cup, wo es unter der Woche Spiele gibt. Da nahm sie das Achtelfinal der Champions League. Also es gibt in den nächsten Monaten sehr viele Doppelbelastungen für Inter und Juve hat die nicht. Und das merkt man, dass Juve da auch eine gewisse Kraft daraus zieht. Und plus bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass Juve im Januar nachlegen wird im Mittelfeld. Denn wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen, Allegri hat ja zwei Mittelfeldspieler verloren. Ich nenne es mal aus eher untypischen Gründen, nämlich Paul Pogba, Doping-Sperre und Nicola Fadjioli, Wett-Sperre. Also da fehlt ihm ja auch Masse einfach, Quantität. Und da deutet vieles darauf hin, dass Juve jetzt, da sie so gut dastehen, da nachrüsten, da ist so ein Rodrigo de Paul zum Beispiel im Gespräch, also auch ein argentinischer Weltmeister. Ich bin mir sicher, dass da was gemacht wird und dann wird es glaube ich darum gehen, wenn es Juve wirklich schafft, einfach dran zu bleiben. Also ich bin mir sicher, dass Juve jetzt da nicht groß vorbeiziehen wird, aber ich glaube, wenn sie es schaffen, bis zum Frühling an Inter dran zu bleiben, dann wird vielleicht auch die Druckkomponente irgendwann kommen, weil Juve weiß halt, wie man es macht, wenn man vorne dran ist. Rabiot jetzt nach dem Derby d'Italia auch zum ersten Mal öffentlich ausgesprochen, wir wollen ein Scudetto. Das hat man so bis jetzt von Juve noch nicht gehört. Und dementsprechend bin ich, also kann ich mir gut vorstellen, wenn sie es schaffen, in Reichweite zu bleiben, dass sie wirklich auf Inter die Weitern für mich der große Favorit bleiben, aber dass sie den Druck definitiv hochhalten.
Und vielleicht werden es ja dann mal mehr als nur ein Tor. Also ansonsten lesen sich die Ergebnisse von Juve so wie früher wie ein Bener-Code.
Ja, wie gesagt, das kann man ja auch nochmal. Ästhetisch kann man das ja völlig zurecht kritisieren, um den Bogen vorher zu Alex zu schließen. Das witzige ist ja, das wissen die Juve-Spieler ja selbst. Also Wojciech Szczerny hat mal vor ein paar Wochen nach einem 1-0 gesagt. Er hat gesagt, ja, wir wissen, dass das ästhetisch nichts Besonderes ist. Aber wir haben halt wieder so eine Gier zum Verteidigen gefunden. Das merkst du ihnen an. Die sind echt, also die zu bespielen, wenn die in der Formation sind, ist unfassbar schwierig. Man muss auch zum Beispiel sagen, Danilo, der Kapitän und ich würde sagen, der wichtigste Defensivspieler fehlt wochenlang schon verletzt. Da war die Frage, okay, jetzt fehlt Danilo. Können die weiteren so stabil sein? Ja, jetzt verteidigen Ruggani und Gatti mit Bremer und die verteidigen halt auch in acht Spielen sechs mal zu null. Also das zeigt dir, dass die Systematik sehr gut ist, dass es nicht nur an der Individualqualität liegt. Und dementsprechend, wie ich gesagt habe, Chesney hat selbst gesagt, wir wissen, dass das nicht weiß Gott, wie schön ist. Aber es ist im Moment erfolgreich. Und dann wird eine allegre Mannschaft gefährlich, falls sie das weiterhin fortsetzen können. Kostić war zuletzt offensiv sehr wichtig, weil wirklich über links dann wieder mehr ging. Hat zuletzt auch einige Tore vorbereitet. Jetzt im derbe d'Italia waren gerade die Außenbahnen. Das war sehr spannend. Du hast angemerkt, beide Seiten hatten riesen Respekt von den jeweiligen anderen Außenbahnen, weil es ja zwei große Trümpfe sind. Und da waren beide erstmal defensive first. Also Kostić war auch sehr tief gebunden. Hat aber dafür gesagt, dass Dumfries nicht viel gemacht hat. Auf der anderen Seite hat Dimarco auch nicht viel machen können, weil Kambiaso da gut verteidigt hat. Aber Kostić ja ist ein Faktor, dass eben wenn es dann ein Isiomschaltmoment ergibt und letzter Satz dazu, da müssen wir jetzt logisch Kiesa nennen, weil Kiesa, das hat man vielleicht auch in der Nationalmannschaft gesehen, ist wirklich auf dem Weg zurück, der alte Kiesa zu werden. Das ist ein absoluter Unterschiedsspieler. Und dann ist Kiesa plus Kostić über links, weil Kiesa spielt schon mehr eine zweite Spitze in dieser Saison, aber kommt auch immer wieder gerne über links, weil das ja sein Lieblingshabitat ist. Und da ist dann Kostić und Kiesa zusammen, die sich da auch ein bisschen reingeben. Manchmal in die Halbspur, der andere macht Raum für den anderen. Das ist schon eine sehr, sehr, sehr gefährliche Seite, gerade die Linke da bei Juha.
Kiestić ist das dann. Ich weiß nicht, ob das in Italien auch so ein Fall ist.
Noch nicht. Ich probiere es mal unterzubringen.
Dann habe ich heute Xavi aus dem Amt geredet. Ich habe einen total dummen Namen überlegt. Was mache ich dann jetzt mit Everton?
Übrigens, apropos Ergebnisse und Binärcode, ich habe es noch mal nachgesehen. Barca hat die letzten acht Spiele jeweils nur mit einem Torunterschied gewonnen. Stichwort, Ergebnisse knapp und so.
Da haben alle keinen Hurricane. So, aber jetzt haben wir noch ein Thema aus der Premier League. Wir haben sogar noch zwei Themen aus der Premier League. Aber das erste davon ist eins, was bestimmt viele mitbekommen haben. Everton, Hendrik, hat Punkte abgezogen bekommen. Wie viele und warum?
Genau, Everton hat Punkte abgezogen bekommen, und zwar zehn. Und zwar für Verstöße gegen die Ingenieus. Wir haben aufgeschrieben Profit and Sustainability Rules, also die Nachhaltigkeitsregeln der Premier League in der Saison 2021-2022. Der Verein hat sich auch schuldig bekannt, zumindest teilweise. Trotzdem ist diese Strafe extrem hoch. Also das ist tatsächlich eingeschlagen wie eine Bombe. Das muss man tatsächlich so sagen. Es war klar, dass da irgendwas kommen wird, weil dieser Prozess schon eine Weile lief, aber dass es dann tatsächlich 10 Punkte sind. Also man hätte gedacht, vielleicht irgendwie eine Strafzahlung oder zwei, drei Punkte oder so. Aber dass es dann 10 Punkte werden, das ist schon extrem überraschend, extrem hart, vor allem wenn man auch sieht, worum es da geht. Also es ist in der Premier League erlaubt, dass Vereine 105 Millionen Pfund Verlust machen dürfen pro Jahr. Everton lag 20 Millionen Pfund drüber. Das ist klar kein Kleingeld, aber verglichen bei dem, was in der Premier League an Geld unterwegs ist, finde ich es auch nicht extrem. Und dass es dann, wie gesagt, 10 Punkte Abzug dafür gibt, hat ja tatsächlich einiges an Aufregung ausgelöst und hat natürlich weitreichende Folgen in jeder Hinsicht. Also erstmal für Everton in der Saison in der Liga. Everton ist ja seit Jahren schon, kämpft seit Jahren gegen den Abstieg, obwohl man sich ja eigentlich als großer, großer englischer Traditionsclub sieht, statt Rivales FC Liverpool natürlich, man eigentlich immer wieder Richtung Europa wollte. Und der auch extrem ambitioniert Geld ausgegeben hat, ja auch gerade ein neues Stadion baut. Und jetzt spielt Everton nicht nur gegen den Abstieg, wie in den letzten Jahren, sondern ist nach diesem Punktabzug vorletzter mit jetzt schon fünf Punkten Rückstand auf einen Nichtabstiegsplatz. Das heißt, also erstmal die sportlichen Folgen sind nicht extrem für Everton. Und das Zweite ist natürlich, und das wird die Premier League und England jetzt noch eine Weile bewegen, dass ja Everton nicht der einzige Verein des bekannten Marzen gegen England ermittelt wird. Also dass man ja auch noch Chelsea hat, die von der Wavewaschung bestraft wurden, wo die Premier League auch ermittelt. Und da geht es tatsächlich um einen Zeitraum 2012 bis 2019, also ein großer Teil der Abramovic-Ära. Und dann hat man natürlich Manchester City, die angeklagt sind, in 115 Fällen wegen Verstößen gegen Finanzregeln. Und das ist ja in Deutschland ausgiebig berichtet worden. Und die Frage ist natürlich, wenn Everton jetzt dafür, dass sie 20 Millionen mehr ausgegeben haben oder mehr Verlust gemacht haben als erlaubt, wenn die dafür schon 10 Punkte abgeboten bekommen.
Wo landet der Liga 3?
Genau, was passiert dann mit Manchester City? Und es wird halt immer schon so ein bisschen so scherzhaft auch gesagt, nein, dann spielen die halt bald wieder League One, also dritte Liga. Und viele City-Fans sagen auch, da waren wir eh schon, das waren immer schöne Auswärtsfahrten. Warum denn nicht?
Das sind aber nicht, das sind die neuen, die alten City-Fans, nicht die neuen.
Das sind aber die alten City-Fans. Die neuen wissen wahrscheinlich nicht, wo Gillingham liegt. Und Pep Guardiola wurde jetzt natürlich nach diesem Everton-Urteil auch schon gefragt. Weil natürlich klar ist, dass das auch auf City abstrahlt und auf die ganze Debatte um City. Und er meinte auch, selbst wenn wir dann irgendwann dritte Liga spielen, dann bleibe ich trotzdem hier. Also, das kann man dann natürlich irgendwie gut sagen und kommt gut an, aber das muss man jetzt wirklich mal sehen, wie sich das auf Manchester City auswirkt, weil die Premier League hier natürlich schon, muss man sagen, einen Präzedenzfall schafft. Also, das gab es noch nicht. Punktabzug wegen Verstößen gegen diese Regeln und auch ein Exempel statuiert tatsächlich. Also, Everton ist schon, die sind nicht unschuldig. Die haben schon tatsächlich unsauber gewirtschaftet. Die haben gegen diese Regeln verstoßen, das stimmt schon, aber das Strafmaß ist extrem. Und es geht jetzt natürlich auch bei Everton weiter. Die haben Einspruch eingelegt, da gibt es eine Berufung. Gut möglich, dass diese Strafe reduziert wird, dass es dann weniger werden als 10 Punkte. Aber das muss man ja mal sehen. Und da ist tatsächlich was in Gang geraten, wo niemand so richtig weiß, wie der Ausgang sein wird.
Also das muss man vielleicht dazu sagen, dass das jetzt noch nicht sicher ist, ob es bei den 10 Punkten bleibt. Gleichzeitig gab es eben andere, also zum Beispiel die Strafe für die sechs Clubs, die in die Super League gründen wollten. Das waren 3,7 Millionen Pfund. Es gibt Vergleich mit Strafen, die die UEFA ausgesprochen hat. Da geht es gegen PSG, Roma, Inter, Juventus. Ich weiß nicht, warum da jetzt Inter und Juventus mit drin hängen. Vielleicht kann man da vergangenen Ligaturen mal sich anhören. Da ging es aber darum, dass die dann Zeit bekommen haben, das in Ordnung zu bringen. Plus auch bei Everton ist es so wie bei allen Vereinen, dass man so rund 90 Millionen Pfund dieses Verlustes, den sie gemacht haben, auf Covid zurückführen kann, also auf die Pandemie. Ich fühle mich gerade auch ein bisschen schäbig, das Finanzgebane eines Premier League-Vereins in Schutz zu nehmen. Sie müssten trotzdem keine Schulden machen, kriegen genug Kohle. Aber das sind alles Sachen, die dann, glaube ich, schon erklären, warum auch der Aufruhr unter Everton-Fans so groß war. Da gab es ja große Proteste, Demos, spontan oder nicht, wo ganze Straßenzüge voll waren mit Everton-Fans, wo eigentlich die Hauptbotschaft war, warum denn jetzt wir? Also eigentlich das alte Balutelli-Motto.
Ja, das ist auch deren Eindruck, dass die Everton-Fans, also es gab jetzt beim Spiel gegen Man United diesen Protest auf, wo dann das ganze Stadion im Grunde rot war, was auch lustig ist, weil Liverpool Everton und dann ist Everton rot, wo dann alle so Plakate hochgehalten haben mit dem Premier League-Logo und Corrupt, also das ist so ein bisschen der Eindruck, dass das halt kein wohlwollender Prozess und kein gerechter Prozess ist, den die Premier League da durchgeführt hat, sondern dass es ein Exempel ist an einem Verein, mit dem man es jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen ja machen kann. Und es ist der Hintergrund des Ganzen auch so ein bisschen, es wird ja in der Premier League künftig diesen sogenannten Independent Regulator geben, also eine vom Staat eingesetzte Regulierungsstelle, die das Finanzgebaren der Vereine überwachen soll und die auch Sanktionen verhängen kann, was natürlich die Premier League nicht gut findet, weil die Premier League davon lebt, dass es alles einigermaßen schrankenlos ist und die Vereine im Grunde wirtschaften können und Geld ausgeben und Vereine verkaufen können, an wen und wie sie wollen. Und diese Strafe gegen Everton wird jetzt auch als Zeichen gedeutet der Premier League, dass man sieht, wir können uns auch selbst regulieren, wenn wir brauchen, wenn man von außen draufschaut. Genau, wir können auch selbst, wenn wir wollen. Und das trägt natürlich dazu bei, noch mal zu diesem Ungerechtsempfinden der Everton-Fans, dass man dort glaubt, das ist gerade irgendwie ein günstiger Zeitpunkt, von dem die Premier League mal zeigen kann, dass sie den Laden im Griff haben, jetzt mal salopp formuliert. Es gibt auch verschiedene Prominente, mit Everton-Bezug setzen sich für den Verein ein. Also ganz interessant, zum Beispiel der Bürgermeister von Manchester, der aber aus Liverpool kommt und Everton-Fan ist, hat einen Brief geschrieben, hat gesagt, hat er als Privatmann geschrieben und als Everton-Dauerkarteninhaber jetzt nicht als Bürgermeister einer Stadt, in der es einen Verein gibt, der möglicherweise bald von einer noch drastischen Strafe betroffen sein könnte. Und der sagt aber auch, also es ist überzogen, es ist ein ungerechtfertigt hohes Strafmaß. Und es gibt offenbar auch das Gerüchteweise, gibt es wohl auch interne Dokumente in der Premier League, die belegen sollen, dass man diese Strafe halt eben auch verhängt hat mit diesem Independent Regulator im Hinterkopf. Genau, und das ist der aktuelle Stand. Genau, also Juwe fällt natürlich ein als Vergleich, aber es gab in England auch mal das Beispiel des FC Portsmouth. Denen wurden mal 9 Punkte abgezogen wegen Insolvenz. Und wenn man jetzt vergleicht, ich mache 20 Millionen mehr Schulden, 10 Punkte Abzug, ich gehe insolvent, 9 Punkte Abzug, da kann man natürlich schon verstehen, warum man das als Everton-Fan vielleicht nicht akzeptieren möchte. Zumal, ich glaube, die Fangemande des Vereins eheleid geprüft ist. Man hat mit dem Eigentümer Farb Mushiri, der vor 7 Jahren bei Everton übernommen hat, hatte man extrem hohe Ambitionen. Wie gesagt, das ist ein Verein, der sich, ich weiß nicht, ob man immer das Beispiel HSV bemühen muss, aber es ist ein großer Verein, es ist ein Traditionsverein, eine große Fan-Basis, nimmt man vielleicht international nicht so wahr, weil man immer nur Liverpool sieht, aber Everton, das ist schon ein großer Verein, ein bedeutsamer Verein. Die Leute möchten oben internationale Plätze mitspielen und man hat das Gefühl, dass man ein bisschen zum Spielball wird von diesem Eigentümer, der wahnsinnig viel Geld ausgibt, aber irgendwie wahnsinnig inkompetent dabei operiert. Also Sean Dice, der aktuelle Trainer, ist jetzt, ich glaube, unter Moschee schon der achte Trainer.
Also das ist überhaupt kein Konzept erkennbar.
Man hatte Ancelotti, man hatte Lampard, man hatte Koeman, man hatte Sam Allardyce, man ist jetzt bei Sean Dice, also ex-Burnley, klassischer Anti-Abstiegskämpfer eigentlich. Also das ist alles relativ wahllos und wie gesagt, auch deswegen, glaube ich, hat man bei Everton dieses Gefühl und bei den Everton-Fans dieses Gefühl, dass man so von allen Seiten es eigentlich gerade abbekommt und man selbst also wieder als Fan einigermaßen unverschuldet jetzt in diese Lage geraten ist.
Und ich glaube, dass das trägt dazu bei, dass die Wut der Everton-Fans auch gerade so groß ist.
Weil Hendrik gerade das Jubelbeispiel angesprochen hat, weil es ja wirklich einen zeitlichen, ja so engen Bezug gibt. Also ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt, weil das war ja eigentlich im Nachgang auch das riesen Thema in Italien, wie das die Premier League jetzt schafft oder ob sie es schafft. Weil es ist ja klar, Everton geht in Berufung. Juwe auch gegangen. Und bei Juwe gab es dann den Fall, die Punkte waren erst weg. Dann waren sie plötzlich wieder da, weil Juwe diese Berufung gewonnen hat. Dann ist dagegen wieder die nächste gerichtliche Instanz angerufen worden. Und am Ende hat Juwe die Punkte wieder abgezogen bekommen. Dadurch wurde ganz klar, das sagen alle in Italien, die Tabelle über ein Drittel oder zwei Drittel der Saison komplett, sozusagen, das hatte ja Auswirkungen auf die jeweiligen Ziele der jeweiligen Mannschaft. Also Juwe war erst mal raus aus den Champions League-Rennen. Dann waren sie plötzlich wieder mit einem Schlag drin, weil die Punkte wieder da waren. Das haben ja auch andere Trainer, Simonin Sargett, gesagt. Wir wussten ja nicht, ist Juwe jetzt zehn Punkte, sind die dran oder sind die weg? Also es ist ja wirklich eine riesen Herausforderung, als Profi-Liga das in Einklang zu bringen, mit den rechtlichen Schritten, die ja jeder Verein dann auch hat. Und da aber das Sportliche nicht auf der Strecke bleiben zu lassen. Und das war, wie gesagt, in Italien eine riesen Sache. Und am Ende ist bei Juwe auch ein bisschen der Eindruck entstanden, am Ende haben sie ihnen genauso viele Punkte abgezogen, dass sie nicht mehr in die Champions League reingekommen sind. Also das ist ein sehr spannendes Thema. Da bin ich jetzt gespannt, wie das in England gelöst wird, weil in Italien hat das die Art und Weise. Also ich rede jetzt gar nicht, ob der Punktabzug okay ist oder nicht, sondern einfach die Art und Weise mit verschiedenen Gerichtsstufen, wie die Premier League das handelt. Das ist sehr spannend.
Und es war ja sogar, ich glaube, Europa League. Also Juwe ist ja gar nicht ein International.
Genau, richtig. Am Ende war es dann, aber unter uns das Wichtigste war, dass die nicht in die Champions League reinkommen. Und am Ende war es dann sogar so, dass sie nicht europäisch spielen konnten. Aber wirklich, dass auch die anderen Vereine nicht darunter leiden, die Konkurrenz, dass da nicht die sportliche, wie nennen wir es, das sportliche Gleichstellungsmarkmel, damit jeder weiß, wie viele Punkte hat jetzt eigentlich der andere effektiv, auf der Strecke bleibt.
Hendrik hat vorhin übrigens den Satz gesagt, man muss sehen, wie sich das auf Man City auswirkt. Könnte man nicht vielleicht eher sagen, ob sich das auf Man City auswirkt, wenn man Man Citys History kennt mit keine Strafen bekommen für Dinge, die eigentlich bestraft werden sollten?
Na gut, aber jetzt mittlerweile gibt es diese 115 Anklagepunkte, und das ist ja schon eine Weiterentwicklung zur Vergangenheit. In der Vergangenheit hieß es dann ja immer, es war verjährt und so weiter und so fort, aber jetzt hat man das ja ganz klar etablieren können, und das wird jetzt verhandelt. Von daher glaube ich, kommt City da jetzt nicht so einfach aus, wie in der Vergangenheit. Andererseits, das muss man natürlich auch sagen, ob die Premier League ihren besten Verein rausschmeißt, das bin ich mir halt auch noch nicht so sicher. Ich tue mich da echt schwer ab. Ich tue mich da echt schwer abzuschätzen, wie es bei Manchester City ausgeht. Aber es werden jetzt hier auch in den englischen Medien Anwälte und Fachleute und Sportrechtler und so weiter befragt. Und die sagen auch, also bei dem, was Everton gemacht hat, das ist das, was die sich geleistet haben als Vergehen, ist am unteren Spektrum anzusiedeln, im Vergleich zu zum Beispiel Chelsea und Man City. Und man hat jetzt halt diesen Maßstab. 20 Millionen bedeutet 10 Punkte Habflug. Und da wird sich die Premier League also wohl oder übel ja in irgendeiner Form dran messen müssen. Und egal, was dann bei City und bei Chelsea entschieden wird, wird es ja für ein extremes Aufheben sorgen. Also entweder, weil die Vereine rausgeschmissen werden, wie gesagt, ich glaube es nicht. Oder weil natürlich dann vollkommen zu Recht Everton sagen könnte, also uns werden hier 10 Punkte abgezogen. Wir steigen möglicherweise ab wegen 20 Millionen. Und Max, du hast es ja gesagt, es gab ja auch tatsächlich ein paar entlastende Faktoren, also Covid. Wie gesagt, bei Everton ist es auch der Stadionbau. Das hat die Premier League auch anerkannt. Man hat aber trotzdem gesagt, naja, ich habe trotzdem gegen die Regeln verstoßen. Also von daher steht das jetzt halt im Raum als Maßstab. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Premier League künftig bei noch schärferen Vergehen sagen kann, ist es jetzt eine Geldstrafe? Oder wird dann am Ende statt mit 10 Punkten Vorsprung, dann ziehen wir den halt neuen ab?
Wobei aus der Champions League hätten sie ja auch geworfen werden sollen und dann kamen sie mit einer Brigade von Anwälten und dann ist es auch nicht so gekommen.
Nee, das stimmt, aber da ist, soweit ich das einschätzen kann, sind die Regeln ja unterschiedlich und die Sachen der Champions League hieß es dann, konnte halt nicht established werden, weil verjährt. Und das ist in der Premier League ja anders. Also da kam es durch die Premier League ganz konkret zur Anklage, von daher liegt der Fall schon anders.
Ja und was man aber noch dazu sagen muss ist, selbst wenn jetzt die Premier League wegen eines staatlichen Regulatus, der mit reinkommen soll oder warum auch immer jetzt immer so streng sein würde, dann ist es natürlich trotzdem eine Verschärfung des Wettbewerbs zu Ungünsten von Teams, die nicht von irgendwelchen Staaten unterstützt werden. Also im ersten Moment denkt man sich dann, oh jetzt wird vielleicht auch Manchester City bestraft, der werden sie vielleicht auch. Dann werden die aber über Sponsoring-Deals, die halt eigentlich versteckte Zahlungs-Unterstützungs- Möglichkeiten des Investors sind, werden die es einfach in Zukunft vermeiden, dass sowas nochmal passiert. Und das ist ja quasi nochmal ein weiterer Hintergrund bei Everton. Das ist eben nicht möglich, weil da haben sie ja Hendrik auch ihre Probleme. Also es wird nach einem neuen Investor gesucht, Triple Seven, steht dann in den Startlöchtern, möchte sich vielleicht Everton holen. Dann kommen mehrere Artikel raus von Liz Hoffman in der Washington Post. Ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, was Wall Street Journal war, glaube ich, wo dann rauskommt. Ah, das ist ja seltsam, die, die so viel Geld ausgeben, die wollen das mit riesigen Rendite Hoffnung machen und die haben das aus Rückversicherungsgeschäften, also Versicherer, die sich nochmal versichern für eben die Versicherung, die sie ihren Endkunden gegeben haben. Und all das kommt da ja noch mit rein. Also Everton hat einfach nicht diesen Start- oder Investor im Hintergrund, der zur Not irgendwie über irgendwelche Kanäle Geld rüberschieben könnte, um eben so einen Corona-Pandemie-Verlust zum Beispiel auszugleichen. Und das ist aber ja nochmal Teil der Hintergrundgeschichte, die zu Everton noch dazu kommt. Dieses ganze Investoren-Thema.
Ja, absolut. Und das betrifft natürlich auch die Frage, was dann dieser Independent Regulator halt, welche Befugnisse der hat, was der machen kann und was der nicht machen kann. Und das geht also Teil dessen, was halt künftig möglich sein kann, ist, dass dieser Owners and Directors Test verschärft werden soll.
Also die Frage, nachdem man Saudi-Arabien reingelassen hat, kann man es jetzt endlich verschärfen, ja?
Ja, genau.
Wer ein Unternehmen darf. Und da ist aber auch künftig, wird es nicht rumgehen, wie ist da möglicherweise die Menschenrechtslage in dem Land, wo der Investor herkommt oder der konkret mit dem Staat zusammenhängt, sondern da geht es dann auch vor allem um die Frage, haben die das Geld, um einen Premier League-Verein finanzieren zu können? Also der Verkauf von Newcastle an den PEF, der wäre auch mit diesem Independent Regulator durchgegangen. Ganz einfach, weil die britische Regierung auch Geschäfte mit Saudi-Arabien macht. Die Premier League möchte das Geld und sie sieht da keinen Grund, da einzuschreiten. Das wäre auch künftig so. Und das ist in diesem Ganzen, ich finde die Idee auch gut, dass man eine unabhängige Behörde hat, die da draufschaut und die diese Exzesse verhindert, vor allem auch in den Leagens drunter, wo sich die Vereine finanziell zum Teil so extrem übernehmen, weil sie an die TV-Einnahmen der Premier League wollen, dass man da im Zweifel einlenken kann, um zu verhindern, dass Vereine kaputtgehen, wie man zum Beispiel bei Bolton Wanderers gesehen hat oder ein bisschen mal darunter FC Bury. Das ist immer so das Beispiel, was da gefühlt wird, dass man verhindern will, dass Vereine sich von Eigentümern im Grunde vor die Wand gefahren werden. Aber die Idee dieses Regulators ist nicht zu verhindern, dass Saudi-Arabien oder die Emirate oder im Zweifel Katar in der Premier League einsteigt.
Das wird auch weiterhin möglich sein.
Da atmen wir doch erleichtert auf. Ich werde zwei Links in die Genres packen, die ich euch beide sehr empfehle, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Zum einen haben wir genau zum FCBerry und zum den Bauten Wanderers, wie Karl-Heinz Rummenigge immer so schön gesagt hat, haben wir mal ein damals noch hieses Kurzpass verfasst. Jetzt ist es im Ligaturfeed, werde ich verlinken. Und das zweite war, weil das konnte ich jetzt nur anreisen, mit Triple Seven. Da hören ja alle Hertha-Fans vor allem auf. Moment, was ist denn da los? Ich habe es schon in der letzten Bundesliga der Männersendung empfohlen. Da gibt es ein Double Pivot Podcast mit Liz Hoffman eben, die das nochmal aufarbeitet, was sie da raus recherchiert hat. Auch das werde ich euch nochmal verlinken. Empfehle ich euch beides sehr. So, jetzt haben wir die Herausforderung, dass wir vielleicht ein bisschen schneller durch die einverbleibenden Themen rattern. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange eure Zeit heute noch ist. Wir springen nochmal zurück nach Spanien und Alex. Da warst du doch derjenige, der uns damals den Trainerwechsel von Sevilla noch beschrieben hat. Hast du uns damals noch gesagt, am 12. Oktober war das der Fall? Hast du uns gesagt, wer da jetzt kommt und was jetzt zu erwarten ist? Und jetzt können wir anscheinend schon feststellen, das lief irgendwie nicht so richtig. Ist das wirklich so?
Nein. Ja, der Trainerwechsel ist verpufft. Also von daher macht es ja wieder Sinn, dass ich darüber spreche. Offenbar hatte ich gar nicht auf dem Schirm, dass ich damals auch das Thema angerissen hatte. Sie haben völlig überraschend damals, also wirklich überraschend, Jose Luis Mendilibar entlassen, den Veteran, der ja völlig überraschend, also eigentlich als Retter kam im Frühjahr. Nach einer fürchterlichen Grottensaison mit Abstiegsampf sollte sie einfach nur stabilisieren und vor dem Abstieg im Endeffekt retten, hat er ja dann geschafft und nebenbei die Europa League gewonnen. Das ist sein erster Titel überhaupt, also ein sensationelles Achievement, weil man ja damit überhaupt nicht rechnen konnte. Wobei Serie A und Europa League, irgendwo kannst du ja doch damit rechnen, wenn sie da mal sind. Aber er hat also einen grandiosen Job gemacht und overachieved. Ja, aber in dieser Saison gab es offenbar aus Vereinssicht nicht diese Weiterentwicklung oder nicht diese ja diesen Gang nach oben in die alten Gefilde, nämlich in die Europa-Gefilde, sondern sie waren wieder im Mittelfeld der Tabelle, gewannen mal, wieder mal unentschieden, wieder mal ein Sieg, dann wieder viele Unentschieden und plötzlich haben sie Mendeleba entlassen und das kam sehr, sehr überraschend. Und jetzt im Nachhinein musst du sagen, das war ein riesengroßer Fehler, dass sie ihn da entlassen haben. Denn Diego Alonso, der Nachfolger, der noch nie in Europa gecoacht hat, statt nur in Südamerika, der, ja, stellt sich etwas weniger gut an als Mendeleba, um es mal wohlwollend zu formulieren. Ein einziger Sieg in neun Spielen gelang ihm. Und das war im Pokal gegen einen Viertligisten. Ansonsten läuft es nicht so gut. Neun Spiele, ein Sieg, vier Unentschieden, vier Niederlagen. Also da hat man sich mehr erhofft, das klappt gar nicht. Punkteschnitt von Alonso übrigens 0,78. Das ist nicht so toll, ne? Der Punkteschnitt von Mendy Libar vorher übrigens 1,47. Also eigentlich doppelt so hoch. Ich glaube, allein daran kann man erkennen, dass es nicht so wirklich funktioniert hat, dieser Trainerwechsel oder dass man sagen muss, das war ein Griff ins Klo. Man hat da wirklich vorschnell überhastet und fast schon grundlos Mendy Libar entlassen. Und unter Alonso wird es nicht besser, sondern wesentlich schlechter. Und jetzt könnte es sein, dass wir demnächst bald den nächsten Trainerwechsel bei sie haben, denn sie haben ja gestern ihr Endspiel in der Champions League verloren gegen Eindhoven nach 2 zu 0 Führung. Es sah ja alles wunderbar aus. Reaktionen der Mannschaft, sie waren auch verdient in Führung, 2 zu 0 ist ja auch ein vermeintlich komfortables Polster. Dann ging es komplett schief. Noch 2 zu 3 verloren, gelb-rote Karte kassiert, Rückstand kassiert, die Eigentor geschossen, auch ein bisschen unglücklich. Und dann in der 90. das 2 zu 3, also Krisenstimmung schlechthin danach, Pfiffe im Stadion. Es gab wohl auch Vorstandrausrufe, um es jetzt mal ins Deutsche zu übersetzen. Also es richtet sich die Kritik nicht gegen Trainer, sondern aus Gründen dann natürlich doch eher gegen die handelnden Personen im Hintergrund. Ja, Krisenstimmung schlechthin und deswegen könnten wir bald wieder den nächsten Trainerwechsel bei Sevilla haben.
Ja vor allem, Sie können jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr die Europa League gewinnen, weil Sie jetzt Vierter in der Champions League Gruppe sind. Ja, wenn Sie gegen La Liga gewinnen auswarzen.
Wenn Sie gegen La Liga gewinnen, sind Sie punktgleich mit La Liga. Sie haben dann den direkten Vergleich gewonnen, weil ich ein Spiel war unentschieden. Dann sind Sie wieder Dritter und spielen wieder in Ihrer Europa League.
Der klassische Sevilla-Weg. Die Champions League Millionen mitnehmen aus der Gruppenphase, um dann in die Europa League zu kommen und die zu gewinnen.
Wenn du aber gestern die Bilder im Stadion gesehen hast, also die Mannschaft, wie die perplex war, das hat sich fast schon nach Abstieg angefühlt. Also wirklich leere Blicke auf den Rängen des Stadions mit Schlusspfiff, sofort leer, drei Viertel leer, wirklich als hätte einer den Stecker gezogen. Das hat sich schon hart angefühlt, als wenn sie eben nicht noch die Chance auf die Europa League haben, sondern als wenn sie jetzt wirklich direkt ausgeschieden, obwohl sie ja wirklich noch den Matchball für ihre geliebte Europa League in der Hand haben. Aber das hat sich schon gestern sehr, sehr krass angefühlt im Stadion und die Bilder haben für sich gesprochen. Man hat auch am Jubel von Alonso gesehen, wie wichtig diese Führung für ihn persönlich war oder wie wichtig ein Sieg gewesen wäre. Dass er da gejubelt hat, als wenn das irgendwie ein Halbfinale oder so wäre. Also es geht schon um seinen Job, das hat er gemerkt. Und ja, es könnte jetzt sein, dass er diesen eben verliert, denn seine Bilanz ist wirklich desaströs. Und deswegen muss man echt sagen, kompletter Griff ins Klo dieser Trainerwechsel. Also er war auch grundlos, auch komisch. Also der Zeitpunkt war ja typisch diese Länderspielpause. So komisch ist er dann nicht, weil da verlieren ja oft die Vereine die Nerven. Aber er war damals wirklich ziemlich unbegründet. Genau, das Spiel gegen Real war das erste von Alonso.
Ach, das war dann der Nachkampf, stimmt richtig.
Genau, genau. Aber Sie hatten, lass mich mal nachgucken, Sie hatten bei Barca nur 0 zu 1 verloren in der 80. durch den Ramos-Eigentor. Also ein Spiel, das auch unentschieden ausgehen kann. Und danach hatten Sie zwei Unentschieden. In Eindhoven, das 2 zu 2. Da kassierten Sie das 2 zu 2 in der 95. Minute, in der Nachspielzeit der Nachspielzeit. Also extrem bitter. Ja, und dann gegen Radio gab es auch ein 2 zu 2. Da schossen Sie aber in der Nachspielzeit den 2 zu 2-Ausgleich nach 0 zu 2-Rückstand. Also da kannst du sagen, okay, Fehlstart. Aber die Mannschaft hat ja eine Reaktion gezeigt. Also nach diesen drei Spielen ohne Sieg, wurde Mendyli bar völlig grundlos, oder nicht völlig grundlos, aber völlig überstürzt entlassen. Ja, wirklich komplette Fehleinschätzung offenbar.
Er hat ja noch keinen neuen Job. Also vielleicht holen Sie ihn ja einfach zurück.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
Der italienische Weg quasi.
Wenn die Europa League-Quali fix ist jetzt am letzten Spieltag, dann sollten Sie ihn wieder zurückholen, damit Sie dann das Ding wieder ziehen.
Ja, also Sie hatten jetzt glaube ich übrigens Sevilla, und da sind wir auch beim Thema Unstetigkeit und Chaos, schlingender Weg und ja, macht man so, mal so, nichts klappt. Ich glaube, es wäre der fünfte Trainerwechsel in 15 Monaten, wenn Sie den jetzt wieder entlassen. Oder es ist schon der fünfte irgendwie so. Also das zeigt schon auf, dass dieser stolze Verein, der ja regelmäßig die Europa League gewinnt, aber irgendwie komplett den Faden verloren hat und von dieser Stabilität regelmäßig sie auf Platz 4, 5, 6 führte in den letzten Jahren, dass sie da komplett, ja wie gesagt, den Faden verloren haben und von einer Krise in die nächste wanken.
Fußball, ein so tolles Geschäft. Aber wir haben zum Glück auch noch positive Geschichten. Wir wollen mal eine Feel-Good-Story. Ja, jetzt kommt eine Feel-Good-Story, nämlich Atalanta in der Champions League. Da hätte ich Bock drauf.
Bologna.
Bologna?
Schau, Atalanta nehmen wir auch noch mit rein.
Die liegen ja nur aktuell auf dem Champions League-Patz, oder?
Nee, die sind auch in Reichweite.
Jaj, meine Güte.
Sind nicht so weit weg.
Ja, okay, stimmt richtig.
Ja, bringen wir mal was Positives. Also, Blick auf die Tabelle. Die Roma ist wieder rangerückt an die Champions League-Plätze. Nur noch drei Punkte hinter Napoli. Aber eben ist da nicht allein als Fünfter, sondern Punkte gleich ist Bologna auch da. Und Bologna hatten wir schon mal, wir hatten ja schon mal Thiago Motta thematisiert, der Trainer, der logischerweise auch jetzt wieder sehr positiv im Fokus steht. Denn das Besondere, also Motta hat letztes Jahr schon eine richtig gute Arbeit geleistet. Bologna hat einen sehr ansehnlichen Fußball gespielt. Aber ich bin überrascht, dass sie jetzt wieder so weit vorne dran sind, weil sie im Sommer schon einen heftigen Cut hatten an, was die Verlust von wichtigen Spielern betraf. Das ging los mit Anatovic ist nicht mehr da. Dominguez und Schauten, das war das Herz, das Zentrum, das zentrale Mittelfeld. Beide Stammspieler wurden verkauft und Cambiaso, jetzt bei Juve auch eine ordentliche Rolle spielt. Mittlerweile italienischer Nationalspieler. Der war nur ausgeliehen. Die haben vieles verloren und haben es aber trotzdem wieder geschafft, wieder sehr weit vorne mit dabei zu sein, was eben sehr viel mit der Art von Thiago Motta zu tun hat. Der wird in nicht allzu langer Zukunft an größeren Fußballschauplätzen tätig sein. Wer weiß. Weil er weiterhin einen sehr ansehnlichen Fußball spielen lässt. Das ist ein sehr flüssiger Fußball, sehr viel Bewegung. Also Bologna als Gegner zu lesen, ist sehr schwierig. Die Grundformation ist ein 4-2-3-1. Aber eigentlich ab Mittelfeld nach vorne, bewegen da sich alle in sehr vielen Rorschaden, sind schwer greifbar, die Außenverteidiger schieben mit an.
Relationismus, oder wie? So wie Din ist?
Thiago Motta, oder wie meinst du? Es ist wirklich ein sehr... Fluid, glaube ich, ist ja mittlerweile so ein Wort, das sehr gerne benutzt wird. Und das passt wirklich, weil du im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes schwer greifst. Und dann gibt es halt so ein paar Spiele. Und jetzt kommt vielleicht, erinnert sich der eine oder andere Bundesliga oder FC Bayern, Beobachter auch Joshua Zirkzee. Ist seit Arnautovic sozusagen im Sommer verkauft wurde, der klare Nummer-1-Stürmer und macht es richtig, richtig gut. Hat schon fünf Mal getroffen, hat dazu noch fünf Großchancen vorbereitet. Das zeigt eben, er ist so ein bisschen so ein Neuneinhalbwirt in Italien bezeichnet als ein sehr spielstarker Mittelstürmer, der gut die Pelle festmacht und der auch technisch aber wirklich in dieses fluide Spiel wunderbar mit reinpasst in diese vielen Positionswechsel. Jetzt am Wochenende hat Bologna Torino geschlagen, 2 zu 0, und Ivan Juric, der Trainer von Torino, wurde danach auf Zirkzee angesprochen und er hat gemeint, Zirkzee erinnert mich in gewissen Bewegungen an Ibrahimovic. Das zeigt eben, dass Bologna das sehr clever gemacht hat. Sie haben Anatovic abgegeben, der die letzten Jahre sehr wichtig war. Der war schon in der vergangenen Saison so ein bisschen mit Yago Mata, das lief nicht immer ganz rund. Und Zirkzee hatten sie ja schon im Sommer 2022 festverpflichtet, haben ihn so ein bisschen im Schatten von Anatovic sozusagen ranwachsen lassen. Und jetzt ist er in diese Rolle reingeschlüpft und macht das wunderbar, wie gesagt. Zirkzee ist so ein Name, dann ein anderer Name, vielleicht Ricardo Calafiori wird den wenigsten was sagen. Das war ein Roma-Talent, der bei der Roma als sehr junger Spieler ja hoch talentiert war. Von dem hat sich dann ein bisschen die Spur verloren. Der war zuletzt in der Schweiz, den hat Yago Mata zurückgeholt, eigentlich ein Außenverteidiger. Und der spielt jetzt zentral, den hat er zum Innenverteidiger umfunktioniert und ist da spielstark, passt da wunderbar mit rein. Zeigt eben wieder, dass Yago Mata wirklich auch in der Entwicklung von jungen Spielern ein sehr gutes Händchen hat. Am vergangenen Wochenende hatte die Bologna-Startei einen Altersschnitt von 24. Also auch sehr viele junge Spieler. Luis Ferguson, ganz, ganz interessanter Mann. So ein einer der Zehner, sag ich mal, der eben überall unterwegs ist. Sehr abschlussstark. Letztes Jahr, glaube ich, hat er acht Saison-Tore. Jetzt ist er schon wieder bei drei oder vier. Da hat Juventus anscheinend auch ein Auge drauf. Also das ist eine Mannschaft, die Spaß macht. Und das Schöne ist, Yago Mata ist logisch in einer extrem starken Position, weil von außen logischerweise ganz viele, oder auch Bologna klar ist, dass Yago Mata nicht mehr ewig in Bologna sein wird, weil er allein auch durch seine Vita als Spieler, was er alles mitbringt als Trippel-Gewinner mit Inter, als ehemaliger Barca-Spieler, also der hat das Standing, um auch bald einen größeren Verein zu haben. Und Yago Mata hat jetzt mal den Nebensatz fallen lassen, wenn er mir im Winter Leistungsträger verkauft, dann höre ich auf. Also es zeigt eben auch, dass er in einer sehr starken Komposition ist und dass Bologna logischerweise jetzt auch einen Teufel tun wird, dieses, sage ich mal, so gut funktionierende Mannschaft jetzt wahrscheinlich im Winter dann auch erstmal sich sozusagen nehmen zu lassen. Dementsprechend weiter in den Auge drauf halten. Bologna ist zum Beispiel auch bisher schon gegen Juve und gegen Inter gespielt, beides mal auswärts, beide Spieler nicht verloren, zweimal unentschieden gespielt und gegen Juve gab es als letzten Punkt dazu eine schöne Geschichte, da haben sie 1-0 geführt und dann gab es eigentlich einen Elfmeter, der ganz klar ein Elfmeter war, den sind nicht bekommen und Juve macht danach noch das 1-1 und nach dem Spiel hat es eine wunderbare Interviewszene gegeben, Thiago Motta wurde halt auf die Szene angesprochen und seine Antwort war, er stand da und hat 20 Sekunden lang gar nichts gesagt, dann hat der Interview irgendwann verstanden, ok, ich verstehe, das ist ihre Reaktion drauf und hat das so gemeint, wollen wir vielleicht über andere Dinge sprechen und Thiago Motta, sehr gerne und dann haben sie Dann haben wir uns wieder ganz normal weiter geredet. Also, er ist ein Mann, der Charisma hat und der mit Bologna weiterhin einen sehr ansehendlichen Fußball spielen lässt.
Erst zweimal hat Bologna verloren. Nur Juve und Inter haben Seidner verloren, nämlich einmal.
Genau, letzter Punkt, sehr starke Defensiv. Hinter Inter und Juve die stärkste Defensiv, aber nicht eben, weil sie tief stehen oder so, sondern weil sie aktiv verteidigen, hohe Ballgewinne gehen früh ins Gegenpressing, machen viel mit Ball. Manchmal lassen sie ein paar Chancen auch noch liegen. Also die könnten eigentlich auch noch, wenn sie noch effektiver werden, nochmals draufpacken. Aber schöne Geschichte. Und wie gesagt, Thiago Motta, schon mal merken, der wird in nicht allzu langer Zeit woanders auftauchen.
Das hatten wir damals schon thematisiert, als Bologna zuletzt in der Ligatur Thema war. Dann weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, Hendrik, was wir in der Premier League jetzt gerade noch behandeln. Denn da gab es gestern, also das hat niemand außer uns mitbekommen, aber wir haben mitbekommen, dass es ein Battle gab zwischen Aston Villa und Manchester United. Wer hat gewonnen?
Na ja, Manchester United hat ja noch alle Chancen, in der Champions League zu bleiben. Alle Chancen wirklich. Und im Endeffekt, ich habe bei United, man erzählt ja seit Jahren das Gleiche eigentlich, von daher würde ich jetzt gerne noch ein bisschen was zu Aston Villa sagen.
Sehr gerne.
Wir sind tatsächlich das Überraschungsteam der Premier League im Moment, sind auch mit einem alten Bekannten, also der FC Sevilla wurde ja angesprochen mit Una Emery, Trainer bei Aston Villa seit jetzt etwas mehr als einem Jahr. Ist Steven Gerrard nachgefolgt. Die Villa-Fans waren, glaube ich, als Emery kamen, so ein bisschen nicht so wahnsinnig begeistert, weil man ihn hier in England natürlich vor allem in seiner Zeit beim FC Arsenal in Verbindung bringt, wo er eine etwas ungünstige Figur gemacht hat, was auch mit seiner Sprache zu tun hat. Er hat versucht, konsequent Englisch zu sprechen. Das war halt nicht immer perfekt. Das wurde ihm hier in England immer nachteilig ausgelegt. Da wurde so ein bisschen zu einer Witzfigur erklärt. Und das bei den Engländern, die ja nun außer ihrer eigenen Sprache überhaupt keine anderen Sprache sprechen. Also das war nicht fair. Insgesamt muss man aber auch sagen, dieses Engagement bei Arsenal lief halt nicht glücklich für Emery. Nachfolger von Arsene Wenger zu werden, direkter Nachfolger, ist vielleicht auch für... Also das hat man ja bei Arsenal gesehen, wie lange die gebraucht haben, um jetzt unser Attentat da so einigermaßen wieder in die Spur zu finden, ist einfach auch wahrscheinlich einer der schwersten Jobs im Weltfußball. Und jetzt bei Aston Villa stellt er seinen Ruf aber komplett wieder her und er arbeitet sich gerade extrem viel an Erkennung, weil er diesen Verein, der auch wie Everton eigentlich ein Traditionsverein ist, große Fan-Basis, aber immer so ein bisschen unter Radar, auch in der internationalen Wahrnehmung, weil er diesen Verein halt wirklich also jetzt auf Platz 4 aktuell geführt hat. Zwei Punkte Rückstand nur auf Tabellenführer Arsenal, einen Punkt Rückstand auf Manchester City, Punkt recht mit Liverpool. Das ist wirklich beachtlich und ich meine, es redet jetzt niemand davon, dass das Aston Villa Meister wird, weil da wird es dann wahrscheinlich, da wird dann an Manchester City oder im Zweifel noch irgendwie Liverpool und Arsenal nichts, an denen wird man nicht vorbeikommen. Aber um die Champions League oder Europa League Plätze kann Aston Villa auf jeden Fall mitspielen. Das ist beachtlich, wenn man sieht, dass die als Emery das Amt übernommen hat, vollkommen ziellos gespielt und gegen den Abstieg gespielt haben. Aston Villa ist extrem heimstark, heimstärkste Mannschaft der Premier League im Moment. Extrem offensiv stark auch, vor allem Olly Watkins zu nennen, der Torjäger. Aston Villa hat hinter Man City zusammen mit Newcastle die meisten Tore in der Premier League geschossen, kassieren auch vergleichsweise viel. Es ist nicht so, dass die eine extrem starke Defensive hätten, von der sie nur profitieren, sondern sie schießen einfach extrem viele Tore. Sie haben zum Beispiel Brighton 6-1 geschlagen. Also das Brighton, das ja auch vollkommen zurecht, der viel gelobt wird, haben West Ham 4-1 geschlagen, haben zuletzt bei Tottenham gewonnen im Verfolgerduell. Also jetzt auch nicht nur gegen Laufkundschaft gespielt. Das ist tatsächlich beachtlich und interessant finde ich, dass Emery bei Aston Villa die effektivste Abseits-Falle im europäischen Fußball etabliert hat. Aber das hat man ja auch gegen Spurs gesehen, wo Spurs auch mehrere Tore wegen Abseits aberkannt wurden, wo man dann immer so ein bisschen dachte, naja, Pech gehabt Spurs und wenn nur irgendwie so 2, 3 Zentimeter und so, dann hätte das Spiel auch ganz anders laufen können. Aber das ist halt schon, das ist halt kein Zufall, dass Aston Villa die Spieler ins Abseits stellt. Also es gibt die Zahl, die, habe ich gelesen, das seit Emery übernommen hat, hat Aston Villa den Gegner 163 Mal ins Abseits gestellt. In der Premier League, der Verein mit den zweitmeisten Abseitsstellungen, war Liverpool mit 93. Aston Villa hat also wirklich einen deutlichen Vorsprung und das ist extrem interessant und das zeigt auch, dass jetzt nicht nur Aston Villa, die haben viel Geld, die geben viel Geld aus, haben auch vor der Saison wieder extrem ambitioniert eingekauft, unter anderem mit Moussa Dhabi von Leverkusen. Aber man sieht auch schon daran, wie sie spielen und auch gerade an dieser Abseilsthematik, dass Una Emery einfach auch ein extrem guter Trainer ist und dass er sich hinbekommt, seiner Mannschaft einen Stil zu verpassen und auch so Instrumente zu entwickeln. Also Stichwort Abseilsfahrer, die dann wirklich eine Waffe sind. Und es ist schade, das anzusehen. Die spielen ansehnlich in Fußball. Und wie gesagt, Aston Villa, leidenschaftliche Fan-Basis. Stimmung bei den Spielen ist Wahnsinn. Also es ist auch einfach aus, ich sag mal, fußballromantischer Sicht. Es ist gerade extrem interessant. Und ich bin gespannt, wo es hingeht. Die spielen jetzt halt nächste Woche gegen Man City. Ich glaube danach gegen Arsenal. Da wird man dann wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen sehen, wo die sich einpendeln. Ob sie wirklich um die Meisterschaft mitspielen können. Wie gesagt, ich glaube es nicht. Aber die werden auf jeden Fall eine gute Rolle spielen können. Gerade auch wenn man sieht, dass so traditionelle Champions League-Anwärter wie vielleicht Man United oder auch Chelsea halt deutlich unkonstanter sind. Dann hat Aston Villa auf jeden Fall eine Chance, sich da irgendwo so um Top 4 zu etablieren. Und ja, das ist eine Entwicklung, die war so nicht abzusehen. Zumindest war sie hier in England nicht abzusehen. Also ich glaube, weil Emery auch insgesamt unterschätzt wurde. Wenn man sieht, was er in seiner Karriere schon erreicht hat, hat er Sevilla, hat auch PSG trainiert. Wie er Real natürlich, den ist der Champions-League-Halbfinale gekommen. Das ist halt schon eine Biografie, die für sich spricht. Aber in England war er halt immer vor allem mit seiner Zeit in Arsenal assoziiert. Und von daher ist es schon eine riesige Überraschung, was er bei ersten Villa gerade leistet.
Also ich sage euch, am Wochenende vom 9. und 10. Dezember, da fallen die Entscheidungen, die hier in der Ligatur angekündigt wurden. Denn wir haben vorhin schon rausgearbeitet, dann wird Xabi entweder entlassen oder er hat die Wochen der Wahrheit durchbekommen. Und dann wird nämlich dieses, also Bournemouth, Manchester City und dann eben Arsenal. Und Arsenal ist eben am 9. Dezember das Spiel für ersten Villa. Dann wissen wir auch, wo Una Emery steht. Und ich muss sagen, wenn ich jetzt wählen könnte, ob wir eine Champions League haben wollen, mit Bologna, mit ersten Villa, ich würde sagen mit dem VfB Stuttgart, ja, go for it, bitte.
Also stop the count.
Ja, bei Girona war ich jetzt nicht ganz das Märchen, ehrlich gesagt, sorry. Da kann ich mich nicht zu sehr verbiegen. Aber ja. Seid mir ab, ich wäre mit dabei. Das wäre ja wirklich ganz, ganz fantastisch. So, wir haben es natürlich geschafft, hier trotzdem wieder in der Überlänge zu landen. Aber so ist das wahrscheinlich einfach bei uns. Aber wir wollen doch schnell unsere Awards vergeben. Das geht ja auch ein bisschen fixer. Das heißt, wie der MVP der aktuellen Phase, Unsung Hero der aktuellen Phase und Moment des letzten Spieltags oder was uns einfach so im Hirn geblieben ist. Du darfst anfangen. Alex, wer ist denn dein MVP aktuell?
Antoine Grießmann ist mein MVP. Sollte, hätte er eigentlich auch gut und gerne der MVP der letzten Saison sein können. Zumindest bei uns im Tikitaka-Podcast wurde er es. Für La Liga wurde Ter Stegen zum MVP der Saison gewählt. Auch nicht ganz unverdient, ne? Und deswegen muss ich hier mal ein Loblied auf Grießmann singen, was wir, glaube ich, in dieser Stelle noch nicht getan haben. Deswegen ist es überfällig. Er ist in herausragender Form, und zwar wirklich im ganzen Kalenderjahr 2023 und auch erst recht jetzt in der Saison, 13 Tore in 18 Spielen. Er ist wirklich der talisman, der Goalgetter von Atletico, der Seele, Herz, Motor, Maschinenraum, alles, was du willst. Kannst noch ein paar andere Wörter benutzen. Also wirklich Dreh- und Angelpunkt. 9 Tore in 13 Spielen in La Liga, 4 Tore in 5 Spielen in der Champions League, das ist ja herausragend. Das sind ja fast schon Haarland-Zahlen. Das kennt man ja eigentlich gar nicht. Bei Grießmann war er eigentlich gar nicht so bekannt dafür, dass er reinweise Tore schießt. Ich glaube, er hat noch nie in der Saison mehr als 15 geschossen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Also umso bemerkenswerter, dass er so viele schießt. Im fantastischen Form, wirklich eingebunden, wie kein anderer in seiner Mannschaft. Wenn du seine Heatmap anschaust, zum Beispiel, es gibt ja die eine Position, die er hat, gibt es gar nicht, weil er überall auf dem Feld ist und wirklich die komplette Heatmap ist hoch.
Weißt du, wie man das in Italien nennt?
In Spanien nennt man sowas ein Toto-Campista, also einen ganz Feldler, der auf dem ganzen Feld überall ist. Es ist wirklich grandios. Er obert Bälle im sechser Raum, lässt da prallen, spielt weiter, kämpft rechts außen, er obert dann den Ball, grätscht an der Seitenlinie, vorne macht er das Ding rein oder legt ab auf Morata. Also wirklich eine Freude, ihm zuzuschauen. Und ja, deswegen mein kleiner Geheimtipp, weil Barca-Kriesel ja, haben wir ja festgestellt, achtet auf Atletico in der Saison. Champions League, klar, weiß man nie, bei K.O.-Wettbewerb, aber in La Liga, da haben sie gute Chancen, mal nicht nur in den Top 3 zu landen, wie immer, sondern vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen weiter oben. Wenn Griesmann in der Form bleibt, gute Chancen.
Trotokampister, sehr schön. Aktuell vier Punkte hinter Girona und Real. Christian, wie haben wir ein Spiel weniger? Ah ja, stimmt, genau, richtig. Ganz genau.
Bei mir, der MVP, da kann sich jetzt die Brücke zu Griesmann schlagen. Ich fand, alles, was Alex gesagt hat, am zweiten Champions-League-Spiel, da war ja Atletico, in Bailazio. Und da habe ich es auch. Das war unfassbar auch sein Fußball-IQ von Griesmann. Da hat er auf Fassenweise in Hälfte 2 nur mit einem Kontakt gespielt. Und jedes Mal Räume geöffnet.
Jetzt hat Jürgen Klinsmann auch.
Das war wirklich herausragend. Weil die Zahlen sind ja schon Wahnsinn, die Alex anspricht. Aber ich finde jetzt auch weg von den Toren. Also so viel Fußball-IQ ist mir extrem hängen geblieben. So, und jetzt schließt sich der Kreis zu Lazio. Denn MVP steht ja für Most Valuable Player, wie wir alle wissen. Und da muss ich momentan Giro Immobile nennen. Es ist unfassbar. Also Lazio, dazu muss man sagen, in der Liga stehen sie alles andere als gut. Da glaube ich nur 17 Punkte, Rang 11 hinter Fro Sinone und Monza. Also zum vergessen. Aber in der Champions League sind sie jetzt eben schon einen Spieltag vor Schluss fürs Achtelfinale qualifiziert in einer Gruppe mit Atletico und auch Fairnord. Und Fairnord ist eine richtig starke Mannschaft, die jetzt sicherlich nicht den großen Namen hat. Aber dass Lazio in dieser Konstellation schon einen Spieltag vor Schluss durch ist, hätte ich nicht damit gerechnet. Und es hat damit zu tun, dass am Dienstag, also gegen Fairnord vor zwei Wochen, hat Immobile das 1-0, das Entscheidende gemacht. Es blieb beim 1-0 und jetzt am Dienstag gegen Celtic. 0-0 lange Zeit, 75. Immobile kommt am Ende 2-0, beide Tore Immobile. Also er ist wirklich so was wie die Lebensversicherung schlechthin. Dieses Tor gegen Fairnord war sein 200. Pflichtspieltor für Lazio. Also für einen Verein, da können dann, glaube ich, nur Lewandowski und... Also es gibt, glaube ich, nur drei oder vier in Europa aktive Spieler, die das momentan vorweisen können für einen Verein. Und er ist auch in den letzten sechs Lazio-Spielen. Hat Lazio nur, hat Immobile alle Tore für Lazio erzielt. Da kann man jetzt drüber reden, dass das logisch nicht gut für Lazio ist. Aber es zeigt eben für mich, ein MVP ist eben der, der den großen Unterschied für seine Mannschaft macht. Und das macht Immobile. Und wie gesagt, allein die Champions League-Quali fürs Achtelfinal, da reden wir ja auch über viel Geld. Das tut Lazio sehr gut. Und dementsprechend, auch wenn Lazio in der Liga sehr enttäuschend da steht, ist er für mich Kommandar um ihn, nicht drumrum.
Stark, Ciro Immobile, das ist doch schön. Und wen darf ich für die Premier League aufschreiben, Hendrik?
Ich würde, wenn das okay ist, vielleicht die Kategorien so ein bisschen verlassen stattdessen, weil ich jetzt nicht gewusst hätte, wie ich das ansonsten hätte einordnen können, ganz kurz einen kleinen Nachruf vortragen auf Harry Venables, über den ich vielleicht ganz kurz was sagen würde. Der gestorben ist am Wochenende im Alter von 80 Jahren und der vor allem in England bekannt ist als Nationaltrainer der Engländer bei der EM 1996, die für ganz viele Engländer vor allem, ich würde mal sagen so Mitte 30 bis Mitte 40, so das fußballerische Erweckungserlebnis waren und das Sommermärchen, also im Vergleich zu Deutschland 2006 drängt es ja so ein bisschen auf. Der Fußball war nicht überragend, weil man hatte halt diese Vielgutstimmung im Land. Man hat die Niederlande geschlagen, 4-1 ist dann bekanntlich dramatisch an Deutschland geschaltet, im halbfinale Elfmeterschießen. Und von Venebels in Erinnerung geblieben ist aber dieses Bild, wie er nach dem Elfmeterschießen Gareth Southgate tröstet und Southgate also wirklich komplett konsterniert ist und wahrscheinlich auch in dem Wissen, was so in den nächsten Tagen in der Öffentlichkeit auf ihn einprasseln wird. Venebels steht da und redet auf ihn ein und lächelt dabei die ganze Zeit, als wäre das halt überhaupt nicht schlimm, was Southgater passiert ist. Und das ist, was tatsächlich alle, also in allen Nachrufen, alle Ex-Spieler, die sich äußern, was hier bei Venebels sagen, ist, dass ein total warmherziger Mensch war, ein total gutes Verhältnis zu seinen Spielern hatte, eine Art väterlicher Freund auch, der für den Fußball in England wahnsinnig viel getan hat und vor allem immer mit dieser EM96, diesem Summer of Love, in Verbindung gebracht werden wird und er ist, wie gesagt, am Wochenende gestorben und das wollte ich ganz gerne erwähnen.
Ja, sehr schön. Das finde ich auch sehr passend. Werde ich die Kategorie irgendwie umbenennen, beziehungsweise ach, die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen ja, was gemeint ist, wenn dann mal diese Art von MVP hier auftaucht. Wen schreiben wir denn als Unsung Hero in die Liste, Alex, bei La Liga?
Einen alten Bekannten, den Hero des spanischen Fußballs, Sergio Ramos möchte ich da gerne nennen. Denn er ist endgültig zurück in La Liga und bei Sevilla ist er so richtig angekommen, und zwar nicht nur, weil er jetzt ein Tor geschossen hat gegen Eintrofen, wenn auch nicht per Kopf, aber in La Liga ist er richtig angekommen, indem er das gemacht hat, was er am allerliebsten tut, nämlich rote Karten sammeln. Er hat mal wieder einen Platzverweis bekommen und nicht nur, dass er einen bekommen hat, ist einfach eine schöne Story. In Anführungszeichen für ihn weniger schön für uns Betrachter, etwas amüsanter schön, sondern auch die Art und Weise. Er hat einen am eigenen Strafraum, einen Gegner abgegrätscht und dann gab es, er war schon gelb vorbelastet, dann gab es die gelb-rote vom Schiedsrichter und wie man das in Spanien natürlich so macht, wie das USOS ist, rannten nicht nur Ramos, sondern auch vier, fünf andere Sevillanos auf den Schiedsrichter zu und redeten auf ihn ein, er zürt und nein, das war kein gelb und schauste bitte nochmal an, offenbar. Also Ramos und Co. baten den Schiedsrichter doch bitte zum Bildschirm zu gehen. Dieser ging zum Bildschirm, sah sich die Szene an, strich seine gelbe Karte und zeigte ihm aber glatt rot, denn er war letzter Mann und hat den Gegner auch oberhalb des Knöchels mit gestrecktem Bein erwischt, also statt gelb gab es dann rot, weil Ramos ihn gebeten hat, bitte schaust du nochmal an. Also auch eine sehr, sehr kuriose, amüsante, muss man schon sagen, rote Karte und damit sammelt er weiter seine roten Karten, denn grandiose Statistik, wirklich fantastisch. Deswegen ist er ein Hero, der hier besungen werden muss. Es war seine neunundzwanzigste rote Karte in seiner Karriere. Seit dem Jahr 2000 hat der Spieler auf Platz zwei übrigens, ein alter Bekannter, Thiago Motta, sechzehn rote Karten gesammelt und Ramos neunundzwanzig. Also eine gewisse Diskrepanz da und deswegen ist er einfach ein Hero, Ramos.
Ich habe diese Szene schon beschrieben bekommen in einem anderen Podcast mit dem Gelb-Rot. Was ich jetzt aber erst sehe, ist, dass Jesus Navas dann auch noch eine rote Karte bekommen hat. Weil sie so draufgegangen sind auf den Schiedsrichter oder dann nachdem dann von Gelb-Rot zu Rot. Fantastisch. Es gibt ja jetzt vom IFAB die Überlegung, dass in einem Testlauf nur noch, ja also Zeitstrafe so eingeführt werden und nur noch der Kapitän des Teams soll in bestimmten Situationen mit dem Schiedsrichter sprechen dürfen, so wie man es aus dem Rugby ja zum Beispiel kennt.
Viel Glück in Spanien und Italien.
Ah komm, jetzt wollen wir hier mal nicht diese Klischees be-besühen, aber du, also sorry, da hat der VfL Bochum genauso große Probleme wie jede italienische Mannschaft. Das können Fußballspieler einfach nicht.
Ja, weil sie es nicht müssen, weil sie ja nicht bestraft werden. So wird ja der Kreistraß, so schließt er sich ja. Deswegen ja, wäre eine Überlegung wert auf jeden Fall, aber für Spanien ist das schwer umsetzbar, weil das gehört da zum guten Ton, zur Kultur, dass man da auf den Schiedsrichter einbrescht und einredet und einstürmt.
Wir sprechen uns nochmal in ein paar Jahren. Vielleicht bekommt man dann deswegen auch so einen Topin als Schiedsrichter da raus. Wenn du in so einer Kultur Schiedsrichter großziehst, sag ich jetzt mal, dann muss vielleicht auch von der Gegenseite ein bisschen mehr Dramaturgie reinkommen in alle Entscheidungen. Also ich hoffe, da tut sich noch ein bisschen was. Dann schauen wir mal in die Serie A. Wer ist da dein unsang Hero?
Mein hat jetzt nicht so einen großen Namen wie Sergio Ramos. Kennen vielleicht nicht so viele. Es geht um Alberto Dossena, das ist ein Innenverteidiger von Caliari. Bis vorletzte Saison hat der dritte Liga gespielt, war nicht groß im großen Fußball. Letzte Saison hat er dann mit Caliari Serie B, als er zweite Liga gespielt, war jetzt auch alles anders als Stammspieler, ist mit Caliari aufgestiegen und jetzt ist er plötzlich absoluter Stammspieler bei Caliari in der Innenverteidigung und hat zuletzt zweimal getroffen. Caliari in den letzten Wochen auch unter Sir Claudio Ranieri auf der Insel der Trainer. Caliari ist sehr schlecht gestartet, aber mittlerweile hat sich im Moment von den Abstiegsrängen zwar nur ein Punkt Vorsprung, aber sie sind aktuell nicht auf dem Abstiegsrang, weil sie zuletzt am Wochenende Torsena getroffen haben, sie gegen Monza unentschieden gespielt, dann haben sie gegen FC Genoa ein direktes Duell davor gewonnen, gegen Juve hat er zuletzt auch ein Kopfballtor erzielt, wo Juve dann auch am Ende nochmal Probleme hätte, weil es 2-1 dann war und eng und Kaljeri eng dran war. Und vor kurzem, das war dieses wilde Fosinone-Spiel, auch ein direkter Konkurrent, da lag Kaljeri zu Hause 0-3 zurück bis zur 70. Minute und hat am Ende noch 4-3 gewonnen durch zwei Tore in der Nachspielzeit und das Viertenteentscheidende hat er vorbereitet. Also er ist jetzt damit auch als Innenverteidiger, hinter dem Marco glaube ich der Scoringstärkste Verteidiger der Liga, zwei Tore, eine Vorlage und ja wie gesagt eine kleine Figur, die man so nicht auf den Zettel hatte, die wie gesagt lange dritte Liga gespielt hat und jetzt mit Kaljeri zumindest wieder mittendrin ist im Rennen, nicht gegen den Abstieg, fand ich einen Namen, den man sicherlich nicht oft hört, der aber zeigt, dass man eben auch vielleicht über den zweiten Bildungsweg, nenne ich es jetzt mal, dann auch trotzdem in der höchsten Liga eine wichtige Figur sein kann, weil er jetzt unabhängig von den Toren auch einfach Stammspieler in dieser Abwehr ist und der Ich bin der Raniere und dementsprechend da sicherlich alles probieren wird, damit Kaljeri am Ende nicht wieder runter muss.
Und man muss ja sagen, zwei Tore bei einem Team, das insgesamt nur 13 erzielt hat.
Sehr gut.
Irgendwann müssen wir auch mal darüber sprechen hier in der Liga Tour. Empoli 8 Tore in 13 Spielen, Verona 9 Tore, Salah nitana 10, Lecce 10, wenn ich es hier gerade richtig... ne, Entschuldigung, Torino 10. Lecce hat immerhin 15, Udinese nur neun, also geht mehr, aber gut, ja sehr schön. Alberto Dossena, den merken wir uns ab jetzt. Dann Hendrik, nachdem du uns ja quasi Unsung Hero und MVP in einem geliefert hast, darfst du mal deinen Moment der Woche nennen. Was war der?
Ja, ist relativ einfach und jetzt sprechen wir doch noch über Manchester United, ist natürlich das Tor von Alejandro Ganacho.
Genau, kein so schnickendes Tor gegen Everton am Wochenende.
Everton, wie gesagt, die großer Fan-Protest vorher und Stadion natürlich extrem aufgepeitschend. Dann noch drei Minuten Flanke von rechts, Dallo in die Mitte. Ganacho muss auch noch ein paar Schritte zur Seite machen, um sich entsprechend unter den Ball zu positionieren. Und dann Fallrückzieher, trifft den Ball wirklich perfekt. Und schlägt oben rechts im Winkel ein über Pickford, Pickford, keine Chance. Und das ist wahrscheinlich nicht nur der Moment der Woche, sondern ziemlich sicher das Tor der Saison. Und es wurden natürlich auch direkt Vergleiche angestellt mit anderen schönen Toren und vor allem Fallrückzieher-Toren. Da fällt dann als Vergleichsgröße immer Wayne Rooney ein gegen Manchester City. 2011 war es, glaube ich, Rooney aber den Ball mit dem Schienbein trifft, also auch nicht hundertprozentig perfekt. Also ist jetzt natürlich Klagen auf hohem Niveau, schon klar, aber dieses Garnaccio Tor ist der perfekte Fallrückzieher, das perfekte Tor und zeigt halt auch, dass bei Manchester United schon auch noch Potenzial da ist. Also Garnaccio ist 19 Jahre alt, spielt seine zweite Saison, hat jetzt auch gegen Galatasaray getroffen und ja, also ganz klar Moment der Woche, mindestens.
Aber absolut, solltet ihr es noch nicht gesehen haben, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann googelt das oder gebt es in eine Suchmaschine eurer Wahl ein absolut fantastisches Tor.
Du musst einen Einspieler wieder reinholen.
Aber es war wirklich der perfekte Fallrückzieher, weil er ihn perfekt erwischt, weil er ihn auch quasi am höchsten Punkt erwischt und weil er ihn gerade noch so erwischt und weil er ihn dann aber auch so ins Tor macht, dass du jetzt auch nicht denkst, du hast ja auch manchmal Fallrückzieher, wo du das Gefühl hast, wäre der Torhüter jetzt nicht überrascht davon gewesen, dass aus dieser Situation ein Schuss wird, dann hätte er ihn gehalten. Bei diesem Tor auf gar keinen Fall.
Ich weiß, warum du dir das Tor so feierst, weil eine flanke Punkt genau ankam.
Genau, er war auch ganz schön frei.
Die flanke kam allerdings auch nicht punktgenau an.
Sie war ja eigentlich zu hoch, deswegen musste er ja diesen Wahnsinns-Fallrückzieher machen.
Die Flanke war halt einigermaßen auf Verdacht in die Mitte gespielt und der Nachhüter Sieg und auch in der Wiederholung muss tatsächlich noch Zeit machen, um sich zu positionieren. Aber das sind jetzt Kleinigkeiten, also es ist tatsächlich, wie ihr sagt, der perfekte Fallrückzieher.
Also genau, wenn ich schon eine ungenaue Flanke fahre, dann wissen Sie, was die Stunde geschlagen hat. Deswegen einfach absolut fantastisch und seien wir ehrlich, damit wird niemand mit halten können, außer Alex hat jetzt aus La Liga hier noch irgendwie was ganz Besonderes, was ich nicht mitbekommen habe.
Nee, ich habe kein Tor, keine Aktion, sondern ich will auch eine Personalien nochmal nennen. Irgendwie roter Faden bei mir ist ja immer Trainerpersonalien und wir hatten das Thema Rückkehrer in La Liga mit Sergio Ramos. Ein weiterer Rückkehrer in La Liga ist Marcelino Garcia Toral, der Trainer, der jetzt zu Villarreal zurückgekehrt ist, war ja am Anfang der Saison bei Marseille und hat ja nach sieben Spielen hingeworfen, das macht man bei Marseille ja offenbar so, und ist jetzt zu Villarreal zurückgekehrt, hat seinen Einstand gefeiert am Wochenende mit dem 3 zu 1-Sieg gegen Osasuna und ist deswegen eine erwähnenswerte Personalie, weil er ja schon bei Villarreal war. Von 2013 bis 2016 hat er die recht erfolgreich gecoacht und wurde deswegen auch als Rückkehrer gefeiert. Villarreal hat das auch natürlich so marketingtechnisch schön romantisierend ins Bild gestellt und willkommen zu Hause in deinem Haus etc. etc. Und wie gesagt, Traumstart mit einem 3 zu 1-Sieg. Villarreal ist ja eine weitere Mannschaft, ähnlich wie Sevilla, die ja durch die Saison schlingern und komplett ihren den Faden verloren haben, den sportlichen und man hofft natürlich, dass jetzt auch schon der zweite, der dritte Trainer in der Saison, Setién ging ja und deswegen, ja, Pacheta war dann ein Nachfolger, wurde auch entlassen, deswegen auch wieder da. Thematik neuer Trainer soll für bessere Zeiten sorgen, aber die Hoffnung ist groß, denn Marcelino hat einen sehr hohen Punkteschnitt, den zweitbesten in der Vereinshistorie von Villarreal. Wer hat den besten Punkteschnitt? Was glaubt ihr? Der Name ist heute schon gefallen, war bei Villarreal als Coach, ob wir es leben. Ganz genau. Das ist der, der ich glaube, also Marcelino hat glaube ich 1,72 und Emery 1,75, also minimal, aber eben zeigt, da sieht man schon auf, die Hoffnungen bei Villarreal sind natürlich groß, dass unter Marcelino sie ja endlich wieder einen Schritt nach oben in der Tabelle machen können und sich stabilisieren können.
Stark, sehr gut. Auch, dass Marcelino noch jemand anderes ist, als der Spieler dabei hat, er gespielt hat. Das weckt auch noch mal Erinnerungen. Aber jetzt will ich nicht auch hier das noch günstig in die Länge ziehen. Christian, was schreiben wir bei dir als Moment der Woche auf?
Ja, der gibt sich in Italien auch relativ von alleine. Was hatten wir gerade? Garnaccio ist 19, oder?
Richtig.
In Italien hat am Wochenende im Milan-Dress ein gewisser Francesco Camarda sein Debüt gefeiert und zwar im Alter von 15 Jahren und ich glaube 8 Monaten. Er ist jetzt der jüngste Serie A-Spieler aller Zeiten, hat bei Milan einen gewissen Paolo Maldini sozusagen den Rekord abgenommen, der mit 16 debütiert hat und echt wunderschöne Bilder. Es war ein Milan-Heimspiel gegen die Fiorentina und es stand schon im Raum, weil Giroud war gesperrt, Okafor und Leao verletzt, Jovic hat angefangen und es stand schon in Tagen davor, wenn er einberufen wird, womöglich kriegt er seine ersten Minuten. Wunderbar, San Siro, die Kurve hat schon während dem Spiel Sprechchöre für ihn, also der ist in der Milan-Jugend groß geworden, sagt, das ist sein großer Traum und wunderbar, als er zum Einwärmen geschickt wurde, hat er die Chöre aus der Kurve mitgesungen. Also echt wunderbare Bilder, er hat einfach, er hat danach gesagt, er kann logisch alle Chöre, er kennt alle auswendig und hat das gesungen und als er dann reinkam, ich glaube in der Minute 82 oder 83, eine riesen Ballyhoo in San Siro, ihm hast du er gelächelt, als er reingelaufen ist, also wirklich so eine kindliche Freude und jetzt gab es einzelne Stimmen in Italien, die auch gemeint haben, boah, muss man einen 15-Jährigen reinwerfen, das kann man definitiv auch kritisch sehen, aber ich würde sagen Stefano Piorli, der Trainer von Milan, ist einer, der ein unfassbar gutes Gespür für auch Sachen, die über den Fußball hinausgehen, zur Erinnerung, er war der Trainer der Fiorentina, als Davide Astori verstorben ist, der wirklich einen sehr, sehr guten Draht, sehr gutes menschliches Gefühl hat und ich würde Piorli nicht unterstellen, dass er das aus Marketing-Zwecken getan hat, quasi um da jetzt irgendwie einen Rekord aufzustellen, sondern Piorli hat auch danach gesagt, für Talent gibt es kein, Talent hat kein Alter, so hat er es genannt, hat er gesagt, der Junge hat unfassbares Talent, eine Zahl dazu, es heißt, er hat bis jetzt knapp 90 Er hat knapp 90 Jugendspiele bestritten und das heißt, er hat um die 490 Tore da erzielt. Klar, das sind diese Geschichten, die kennen wir von früher auch, wenn dann die Mini-MBP ist und Mini-Messes eben rumlaufen. Deswegen, ich will jetzt auch nicht, die Geschichte ist ja logisch auch die, man soll dem Jungen auch nicht zu viel Verantwortung auferlegen, aber ich würde den Piolli-Faktor da wirklich nicht außen vor lassen, weil Piolli hat ein sehr gutes menschliches Gespür und deswegen würde ich eben diese Marketing-Nummer eigentlich fast bei Piolli ausklammern. Er durfte jetzt gegen Dortmund am Dienstag, weil ja da auch wieder Personal sehr wenig war, durfte er noch gar nicht spielen, weil in der Champions League die Regel gilt, unter 16 darfst du nicht spielen. Dementsprechend wird er aber sicherlich wahrscheinlich die nächsten Wochen auch immer wieder mal auf der Bank sitzen und die anderen Spieler haben auch gesagt, er ist unfassbar reif für sein Alter. Auch Piolli hat gesagt, der ist kein 15-Jähriger sozusagen, obwohl er noch 15 im Pass stehen hat und dementsprechend schauen wir mal, was da die nächsten Wochen und Monate daraus wird. Er ist ein Riesentalent und das war wirklich, wie gesagt, allein dieses Bild, er läuft zum Aufwärmen und singt die Chöre mit ein wunderbares Bild.
Also ich sehe schon bis zur 82. Minute hattest du noch keinen Moment der Woche und dann hast du Piolli gefragt, kann man da noch was machen? Und er hat geantwortet, ja, kann man. Und gleichzeitig gibt das uns allen auch Hoffnung, wenn Talent kein Alter kennt, dann fühle ich mich, weiß nicht warum, gleich viel, viel besser.
Was dann noch alles möglich ist.
Also wirklich, ab jetzt ist nur noch der Horizont das neue Limit. Ach, egal. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht, mal wieder auf die Europäischen Ligen zu gucken. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Alex Treuker. Ich werde verlinken, wo man dir folgen kann und auf Viva la Liga kann man dich lesen und im Tikitaka Podcast kann man dich hören. Danke, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Herzlichen Dank an Hendrik Buchheister. Kauft alle sein Buch. We Call It a Klassiker, die Engländer, der Fußball und wir erschienen bei Pieper. Wunderbares Weihnachtsgeschenk. Danke dir, Hendrik, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Und herzlichen Dank natürlich an Christian Bernhardt hier an meiner Seite. Nicht in allen sozialen Netzwerken vertreten, das wird immer noch hin und wieder thematisiert von Hörern und Hörern, denen du fehlst, aber...
Kritisiert auch.
Kritisiert. Ja, aber wenn wir sehen, was für ein zufriedener Mensch er ist, dann kann man eigentlich auch nur sagen, warum haben wir das nicht getan. Also danke dir, Christian, dass du mit dabei warst.
Danke, Max, für die Einladung.
Und euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, danke ich für die Aufmerksamkeit. Empfehlt den Rasenfunk gerne weiter, bewertet uns auf den Plattformen eurer Wahl und unterstützt uns auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Könnt ihr diesem supporters club beitreten. Auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr für Weihnachten shoppen und darüber hinaus natürlich. Und dann herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund und geht mal auf rasenfunk.de, denn es gibt eine Fülle an Sendungen, die ihr hören könnt. Allein zur Bundesliga sind zwei diese Woche erschienen und es geht ja täglich eigentlich bei uns weiter. Danke fürs Zuhören, bis bald mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.